GOOD MORNING WE'RE GOING TO
STARTED.
FIRST LOWER THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THIS THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT RELATIONS
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THAT'S THE STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS
ON INTERACTIONS BETWEEN PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WALKING THE STATE CAPITAL LET'S
THINK ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE TODAY OBVIOUSLY.
EVERY COMMITTEE IS MEETING THE
BUILDING SO MOST MEMBERS ARE
SOMEWHERE EITHER AUDIT COMMITTEE
PRESENT A BILL ARE SINGLE
COMMITTEE SO. THE BE FLOWING IN
AND OUT THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
LOTS LIKE THAT THE PRISONERS
THERE AGREED TO SHARE THEIR
PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES ON THE ISSUE
SURROUNDING INTERACTIONS BETWEEN
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL DISABILITIES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IS HEARING LOOKS FOR EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE TO ENHANCE
THE COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
FIRST RESPONDERS IN A MILLION IS
ABLE COMMUNITY. AND HOW WE MAY
BE ABLE TO PROMOTE THESE TYPES
OF PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE.
TOO OFTEN FIRST RESPONDERS
ESPECIALLY LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
DISPATCHED TO CALLS FOR SERVICE
REQUIRE INTERACTION WITH THOSE
MEN OF MIDDLE DISABILITIES.
THESE CONTACTS CAN RANGE FROM A
DISABLED PERSON OR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS REQUESTING A LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE.
FOR GENERAL ASSISTANCE TWO
INCIDENTS IN WHICH THE MILIEU
SAY BOTH IN THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
MEMBERS ARE IN CRISIS.
HIS TITLE CALLS INCLUDED QUEST
IN WHICH MILLIONS ABLE PERSON
THEIR FAMILY OR A BYSTANDER IS A
WITNESS TO THE EVENT. A VICTIM
OR AS IN MANY CASES THE FAMILY
NEEDS HELP LOCATING A MISSING
RELATIVE WITH MENTAL DISABILITY.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HAVE NO
IDEA WE PERSONS MIDDLE
DISABILITY WHICH WAS THE OFFICER
IN THE MILLIONS ABLE AT A
DISADVANTAGE FOR A QUICK AND
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME.
THESE INTERACTIONS POSITION OF
CAN CHALLENGE TODAY'S PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES BECAUSE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSE TO CALLS FOR
SERVICE WITH MORE DISABLED
PERSONS AT TIMES IS INEFFECTIVE.
FIRST RESPONDER CONTACTS OF
MILLIE DISABLED PERSONS ARE
COMMONPLACE.
THE SYSTEM THERE SOME ESTIMATES
THAT UP TO THIRTY PERCENT OF OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION SUFFER
SOMETIME TYPE OF MIDDLE
DISABILITY.
THE TO SIX SHOW THEIR POSSIBLY
FIVE PERCENT OF US RESIDENTS
HAVE A SERIOUS MENTAL DISABILITY
AND MANY MORE HAVE NO
DISABILITIES. THAT CAN AFFECT
OUTCOMES BETWEEN FIRST
RESPONDERS. IN THE PERSONS IN
NEED.
FURTHERMORE IS ESTIMATED THAT
SEVEN PERCENT OF ALL PLEASE
CONTACT IN JURISDICTIONS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR MORE PEOPLE
INVOLVE INTERACTIONS. DISABLED
PERSONS.
A RECENT THREE CITY STUDY SHOWED
NINETY PERCENT TO PERCENT PATROL
OFFICERS HAVE AN AVERAGE OF SIX
CONTACTS WITH A MILLION CIVIL
PERSON EACH MONTH.
THIS IS A LOT OF CONTACT WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE MUST FIND A
WAY TO SURVIVE MILLION STABLE.
POPULATION MUCH BETTER.
WORLD'S WAYS FOR THE FIRST
RESPONDERS TO KNOW THEY'RE
RESPONDING TO A SITUATION THAT
INVOLVES SOMEONE WITH MIL
DISABILITY.
TODAY YOU'LL SEE AND HEAR FROM
SEVERAL PROGRAMS THEIR
SUCCESSFUL IN DOING JUST THAT.
THESE PROGRAMS GIVE FIRST
RESPONDERS INVESTOR INFORMATION
ON INDIVIDUAL WHO STRUGGLING
WITH MELISSA BUILDING. AND MAYBE
A CRISIS.
IS A THIRTY YEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT
VETERAN I CAN TELL YOU THIS TYPE
OF INFORMATION BEFORE THE
OFFICER FIREFIGHTER RISE IS
CRUCIAL IN PROVIDING SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES DURING CALLS FOR
SERVICE.
THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS
THE FIRST RESPONDERS THE
INFORMATION AND TOOLS TO PUT A
CALL THE NONTRADITIONAL
RESPONSE.
ME THE SPECIAL NEEDS OF THE
MIDDLE IS ABLE.
MY COLLEAGUES ARE HERE'S THE
CHEMICAL OPENING STATEMENTS SO I
SPENT THIRTY YEARS AS A CAPTAIN
OF THE SECOND WAS SHERIFF
DEPARTMENT SO.
.
READ A LOT OF MILLIONS ABLE
FOLKS I WAS THE GEL COMMANDER
FOR DOWNTOWN JONES.
PRETTY SAD WHEN YOU'RE JAILS
HAVE LARGER INPATIENT WARDS IN
YOUR MENTAL HEALTH INSTITUTIONS
SO SOMETHING WE TO CHANGE. ONE
OF OUR KIDS FOR GOVERNOR.
TALK ABOUT INSTITUTIONALIZING
PEOPLE OF MIDDLE ILLNESS THAT'S
NOT THE SOLUTION THAT'S OVER
HERE THEY TRY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
AND WE CAN DO BETTER AND WE MUST
DO BETTER SO I LOOK FOR HEARING
FROM. GOTTEN DYNAMICS PRISONERS
HERE TODAY SO. WE CALL WALK AWAY
AND. AND MY COLLEAGUES GET HERE
AND JOIN US.
REALLY MAKE IMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA NO MIDDLE HEALTH IS
AN ISSUE.
IT'S NOT SHOULD BE STIGMATIZED
HAPPENS TO A LOT OF FOLKS.
AND WHEN YOU DEAL WITH IT AND
AND MAKE IT AS BEST AS WE CAN.
ESPECIALLY THE INTERACTION THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE DON'T WANT TO
SEE SOMEONE.
GET INJURED OR HURT AND I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD METHODS
APPROVING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING PRACTICE RIGHT NOW. THAT
WE CAN.
GETS INFORMATION ON HEALTH WE
TAKE A STATE LIKE.
SO GO AND START WITH OUR.
FIRST PANEL ITS I COMMUNICATE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT PROTECT
THIS.
FROM PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND OUR PANEL ONE.
ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE
DISABILITIES THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND JORDAN LINDSAY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE CAN MORNING THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR.
STAFF THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND AND WHAT IT.
TIMELY WHAT OPPRESSION
OPPRESSION MOMENT WE ARE IN TO
BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT. THE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY.
HERE IN OUR STATE CAPITOL. AND
IN A TIMELY OPPORTUNITY IN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'RE
LEADERSHIP BRINGING YOUR
BACKGROUND TO THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AS YOU ARE ARE AWARE OF BETWEEN
INTERACTIONS.
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE
DISABILITY BECAUSE WE AS YOU
MENTIONED YOUR OPENING REMARKS
WE IS CALIFORNIANS CAN DO
BETTER.
AT THAT INTERACTION.
MY NAME IS JORDAN LENSING AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE ARK OF CALIFORNIA THE RQ
CALIFORNIA. HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
OVER FIFTY YEARS REPRESENTING.
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE ARK IS
ALSO A A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
WITH CHAPTERS THROUGHOUT ALL OUR
STATE AS WELL AS THROUGHOUT MANY
OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT THE ARCS PRIORITY.
HAS A THEIR EXPERTISE HAVE HAVE
SHIFTED OVER THE YEARS IN AND.
RECENTLY ONE OF OUR MAIN
PRIORITIES
HAS BEEN ON THIS EXACT ISSUE
WHICH IS WHY. THE ARK DEVELOP
THE NATIONAL CENTER ON CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND DISABILITY.
AND OUR GOAL WITH THE CENTER IS
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
RESPOND TO GAPS.
AN EXISTING SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
DISABILITIES.
AND THIS IMMENSE IN CRITICAL
NEED.
AND THE THE GAP.
IN WHAT HAS BEEN EXPERIENCE ON
THE GROUND BETWEEN THE
INTERACTION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
DISABILITY HAS BEEN KNOWN FOR A
LONG TIME.
BETWEEN IT IN THE ADVOCACY
COMMUNITY.
AND IT TOOK SOME CATALYST THOUGH
TO REALLY BRING THE NATIONAL.
CENTER TO THE FOREFRONT AS A
PRIORITY IN IN THOSE CATALYSTS
ARE OR STORIES IN THEIR STORIES
THAT TIME MANY OF US ARE
FAMILIAR WITH.
TRAGIC STORIES ON
EVEN SAILOR YOUNG MAN WITH DOWN
SYNDROME IN MARYLAND OR.
WEST KLEINER A YOUNG MAN.
WITH AUTISM IN FLORIDA CHARLES
KINSEY DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL FOR YOUNG MEN IN
FLORIDA.
BUT.
AS AS THOSE STORIES AND.
WON'T WORK CATALYSTS FOR
DEVELOPING THE NATIONAL CENTER
ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
DISABILITY AND CATALYST.
FOR THIS BECOMING A REAL
PRIORITY IN THE FOR THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
.
MY HOPE AND I THINK OUR HOPE IS
NOT TO.
DIVE INTO.
STORIES OR TRAGEDIES AND SPECIAL
NOT TO POINT FINGERS BUT OF
COURSE RATHER TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
SO THAT WE IS CALIFORNIA CAN DO
BETTER AND MOVE FORWARD.
SO I'M IN FINDING SOLUTIONS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL
CAN A START AT THE SAME PLACE
AND WHAT I JUST WANT TO SHARE IS
SOME.
SOME STATS AND SOME INFORMATION
AS A AS A STARTING PLACE FOR OUR
DIALOGUE TODAY.
AND DISABILITY WHAT WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT WHEN WE ARE
TALKING TO PEOPLE DISABILITIES
OF COURSE THEY COME INTO A
VARIETY.
AND.
.
A A PHYSICAL DISABILITY WHICH A
A PERSON MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
STAND OR LAY DOWN OR PUT THEIR
HANDS UP.
A PERSON WHO IS DEAF WHO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO HEAR COMMANDS GIVEN
BY AN OFFICER. PERSON WAS BLIND
YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO SEE AN
OFFICER.
A PERSON HAS AUTISM WHOSE
BEHAVIOR AND A HIGH STRESS.
OR HIGH STIMULUS SITUATION MAY
BE INTERPRETED AS NON COMPLIANCE
OR EVASION OR EVEN AGGRESSION.
A PERSON WITH FETAL ALCOHOL
SPECTRUM DISORDER.
WHO MAY NOT HAVE ANY PHYSICAL
APPEARANCES OF DISABILITY BUT
MAY LACK MENTAL CAPACITY?
TWO A FALL COMMANDS IN A CERTAIN
SITUATION.
A PERSON WITH EPILEPSY PERSON
WITH DOWN SYNDROME.
PERSON WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES
THE THIS IS THERE IS A WIDE
RANGE WHICH MAKES THE CHALLENGE.
A DIFFICULT
BUT A STARTING PLACE FOR US TO
BEGIN. NOTING THAT THERE ARE IT
ARE MANY DISABILITIES.
AND.
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS THE ABILITY
AND OPPORTUNITY.
TO MEET THEM IN MANY PLACES.
ALSO SOME STATS ACCORDING TO THE
UCLA CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH.
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
SEVEN HUNDRED THREE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
EN THE NUMBER WILL DOUBLE
DOUBLE IF YOU COUNT THOSE WHO
MAY BE BLIND OR DEAF.
.
AND ADDITIONAL STATS.
WHICH CAN BE ALARMING BUT. UP
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BEGIN WITH
IS THAT IN GENERAL.
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL OR
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES.
OUR THIRTEEN PERCENT MORE LIKELY
TO BE IT ARRESTED AS JUVENILES
OR YOUNG ADULTS AND PEOPLE FREE
OF DISABILITY.
AND THIS IS ACCORDING TO
REPORTING AMERICAN JOURNAL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES.
THAT CHANCE WIDENED BY SEVENTEEN
PERCENT WITH MORE THAN FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT OF AFTER.
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES BEEN
ARRESTED BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY EIGHT.
SIMILARLY MORE THAN FORTY SIX
PERCENT OF HISPANICS WITH
DISABILITIES.
TO BE ARRESTED AND COULD BE
EXPECTED TO BE ARRESTED AS.
A CHILD OR YOUNG ADULT.
AS THE IS STATS AND THESE
PRIORITIES HAVE GROWN.
SO HAVE OUR INITIATIVES.
IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND I AM
EXCITED IS SURE YOU ARE AS WELL
TO HEAR MANY OF THOSE TODAY.
.
ONE THING THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
IS.
A PROGRAM THAT WE CALL PATHWAYS
TO JUSTICE.
AND PATH WHICH A JUSTICE WHICH
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT IS A
FIELD TESTED CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND DISABILITY TRAINING PROGRAM.
PILOTED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THAT PROVIDES TRAINING
TO THREE PRIMARY AUDIENCES LA
ENFORCEMENT LEGAL PROFESSIONALS.
AND VICTIMS SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS.
AND MORE THAN TRAINING AND
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER TRAINING
INITIATIVES PATHWAYS TO JUSTICE
DOES NOT RELY ON TRAINING ALONE.
BUT HELPS COMMUNITIES.
AND STATES ADDRESS KEY BARRIERS
TO JUSTICE FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND ABOUT TO
DISABILITIES.
AND DISCUSS PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS
THAT WORK BEST FOR THEM.
A TRAINED OVER THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THROUGH PATHWAYS TO JUST
PROGRAM. AND YOU'LL HEAR
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT A PROGRAM
THAT WAS HELD IN VENTURA AND IN
THE SUCCESSES THAT HAPPEN AS A
RESULT OF THAT.
SPECIFICALLY JUST TO CLOSE
MISTER CHAIR.
SOME POLICIES THAT WE.
CONTINUE TO STRESS ON IN THIS
DISCUSSION ARE THE FOLLOWING.
AND ONE THAT SUPPORTING POLICY
THAT ENHANCES TRAINING OBVIOUSLY
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT ALSO
FURTHER DOWN THE LINE FOR
PROSECUTORS IN PUBLIC DEFENDERS.
AND ALSO WANTS AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH A DISABILITY IS IS IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE SUPPORTED THROUGHOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE.
POLICIES THAT ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO SENTENCING
REDUCTION PROGRAMS WITH NEEDED
ACCOMMODATIONS IN SUPPORT.
POLICIES ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES GET THE NEED
TO SUPPORT IF THEY ARE
INCARCERATED.
POLICIES THAT STRESS THE ALREADY
EXISTING MANDATED REPORTING
LAWS.
AROUND DEPENDENT ADULTS AND
PEOPLE DISABILITIES.
AND FINALLY POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A BETTER
SYSTEM FOR IDENTIFYING
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOP
DISABILITIES AND ALL STAGES OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I'M EXCITED TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
IT AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION MY COMMENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOUNG QUESTION HIS HOUSE
THE PATHWAY FOR JUSTICE FOUNDED
FROM I'M SORRY FUNDED FUNDED.
VARIOUS GRANDSON THROUGH
FEDERAL DOJ.
AND SOME THROUGH GRANTS ARE
FUNDED THROUGH THE NATIONAL THE
WHOLE NATIONAL CENTER ON PROMOTE
JUSTICE AND DISABILITY FUNDED
THROUGH ABOUT THREE DIFFERENT
MAJOR GRANTS AT OUR NATIONAL
OFFICE IN DC. I'M SOME OF IT
THROUGH FEDERAL FUNDING HOWEVER
AND DOWN I THINK OUR NEXT PICK
PILLS LEGAL SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
TO.
THE PROGRAM NOW AND I WAS HELD
A MENTOR. BUT I CAN FIND OUT
EXACTLY WHICH.
FUNDING SOURCES ARE FOR
PATHWAYS TO JUSTICE IF YOU LIKE
EMIGRATE AND YOU WORK WITH
POSTED ALL.
IN CALIFORNIA WE DO YES AND IN
POST THERE IS A. A TWO HOUR.
TELL COURSE
WHICH ARE ON DEPENDENT ELDERLY
DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE WHICH IS
AN EFFECTIVE TO OUR TELE COURSE
HOWEVER.
FROM WHAT I'VE LEARNED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE IT CHANGE FROM
MANDATORY TO VOLUNTARY. AND.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
DEFINITELY RECOMMEND IS TO.
CREATE MORE MANDATORY TRAINING
IN THIS AREA. RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
THANK YOU.
I'M A BIGGER APARTMENT SOBRE
SPEAKERS.
.
THE ARK VENTURA COUNTY PETTY
SHOWS EXECUTOR ACTOR FOR
PATHWAYS JUSTICE INITIATIVE.
AND ALSO BRUCE WILSON CO. OF.
IF I NEED HELP DOT ORG.
GOOD MORNING MORNINGS.
AND YOU GUYS.
SOME COMMERCIALS ALL.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. MORNING I
AM PATTY SHOWS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ARC OF INTER
COUNTY. WE SUPPORT SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. ANDY
IS A YOUNG MAN EMERALD IN OUR
TRAINING FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAM. ONE MORNING HE WAS
DRIVING FROM HIS APARTMENT TO A
STATE PROGRAM.
AND WAS IN A MINOR CAR ACCIDENT.
AND EMPLOYEE HAPPEN TO BE
PASSING BY ON HER WAY TO WORK
AND SAW THE INTERACTION AND I
KNEW IT WAS NOT GOING WELL
BETWEEN AND IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SHE STOPPED AND WAS ABLE TO
INTERVENE BEFORE ANYTHING WAS
ESCALATED. AND HE HAS AUTISM
WOULD NOT LOOK AT THE OFFICER
WAS NOT RESPONDING TO
INSTRUCTIONS.
AND THE OFFICER THOUGHT AND HE
WAS UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF DRUGS
OR ALCOHOL.
THIS IS AN UNCOMMON IT'S
REPORTED THAT ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY HAVE
LITTLE OR NO OBVIOUS INDICATION.
WHICH MAKES RECOGNITION
DIFFICULT.
LAST YEAR I CHAPTER HOSTED SIXTY
LONG FOR CEMENT LEGAL
PROFESSIONALS.
AND.
VICTIM SERVICES PROFESSIONALS
AT A PROGRAM.
CALLED PATHWAYS TO JUSTICE.
PATHWAYS TO JUSTICE IS A ONE DAY
TRAINING.
AND.
THE PURPOSE IS TO INCREASE
AWARENESS AND RECOGNITION OF
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND A FORMER STRONG PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
DISABILITY PROFESSIONALS.
WE THINK WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
THAT ENDEAVOR. ATTENDEES LEARNED
ABOUT DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY TYPES
OF BEHAVIOR LANGUAGE IN
PROCESSING.
THEY WERE ARMED WITH FACT SHEETS
AND TIP CARDS TWO.
REMIND THEM OF WHAT TO LOOK FOR
IF THEY COME ACROSS SOMEONE. OF
JUST A SIMPLE THINGS LIKE AS A
PERSON SENSITIVE TO SOUND OR
LIGHTS ARE THEY AVOIDING EYE
CONTACT.
AND TO COMMUNICATE MORE CLEARLY
TO INTRODUCE SOME SOLACE CALMLY
AND QUIETLY.
AND TO USE SIMPLE LANGUAGE AND
GIVE AMPLE TIME FOR RESPONSE.
UP PEOPLE WITH IT INTERVIEWS
WITH IT DE UM ARE ONE TO THREE
PERCENT OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION. AND IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT THEY REPRESENT BETWEEN FOUR
AND TEN PERCENT OF THE PRISON
POPULATION IT WAS WAS I DID YOU
STAND FOR BUT INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AN ESTIMATED SEVENTY PERCENT OF
YOUTH WITH DISABILITIES ARE
INVOLVED IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. AND MOST IN A MINOR
OFFENSES.
ONE AND SIXTY EIGHT CHILDREN ARE
BEING DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDER. A SURVEY OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM AND
THEIR FAMILIES INDICATED THAT
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM HAD BEEN
THE VICTIM OF A CRIME. TWENTY
THREE PERCENT HAD BEEN. IN
INTERACTIONS WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS DUE TO WANDERING OR
ELOPING.
AND THREE PERCENT REPORTED BEING
COERCED TO COMMIT OR PARTICIPATE
IN A CRIME.
FETAL ALCOHOL SYNDROME IS A
SPECTRUM OF CONDITIONS THAT CAN
OCCUR TO A FETUS WHEN A MOTHER
DRINKS ALCOHOL WHEN SHE IS
PREGNANT.
HIS LIFELONG WITH NO CURE.
AND IT'S A HIGHER PERCENT
PREVENTABLE.
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH FETAL ALCOHOL
SYNDROME HAVE BEEN IN JAIL OR
PRISON AT SOME POINT. SIXTY
PERCENT HAVE A HISTORY OF
TROUBLE WITH THE LAW.
AND THE AVERAGE AGE AT WHICH A
CHILD WITH FETAL ALCOHOL
SUSTRANS.
SYNDROME BEGINS A HAVING TROUBLE
WITH THE LAW IS TWELVE YEARS
OLD.
VENTURA COUNTY OFFICERS RECEIVE
SOME TRAINING IN IT DE AND THERE
CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING.
BUT THEY FOUND THAT THE IN DEPTH
PATHWAYS TRAINING WAS
INVALUABLE.
THEY TOLD US ABOUT AN APT THEY
USE CALLED ICON UP WHICH IS A
SECURED OF A SOURCE OF
INFORMATION ABOUT A PERSON AND I
THOUGHT THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO INCORPORATE SOME OF WHAT THEY
LEARNED. AT PATHWAYS TO JUSTICE
TO HELP THEM IDENTIFY A PERSON
WITH AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
SOONER.
THEY ALSO LEARNED THAT THEY HAD
A PARTNER IN THE ARK. WE HAVE
PROGRAMS AND.
VIRTUALLY EVERY COMMUNITY IN
VENTURA COUNTY AND THEY KNOW
THEY CAN CALL US ANYTIME. WE
WERE INVITED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF A FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER. BEING LED BY THE VENTURA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
THAT.
PRO THAT THE ENDEAVOR IS UNDER
WAY AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO
EMPLOYEES SERVING ON THAT WORK
GROUP.
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL. AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
LIVING AND THRIVING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THERE VOLUNTEERING
IN PARTICIPATING AND WORKING AND
WORSHIPPING WITH ALL OF US SIDE
BY SIDE.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO INVOLVED IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OUR HOPE IS THAT AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION MAY CHANGE SOME OF
THOSE OUTCOMES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER WILSON.
CHECK IT OUT PASS THIS UP TO YOU
ARE ABSOLUTELY.
WE'LL HAVE THE HEALTH CODE TO
GET FOR YOU.
MAYBE PASSED.
I. AMBRUS WILSON FROM IF I NEED
HELP AND I'M A. PRETTY PROACTIVE
AUTISM DAD
AND MY WIFE AN I HAVE A SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD SON NAMED JAY.
AND HE'S REALLY IMPROVING
TREMENDOUSLY WITH I'M THERAPY HE
HAS AUTISM.
AND HE STILL IS.
WANDERING RISK BECAUSE EVEN A
FEE AND IF HE GETS OUT HE WON'T
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY HIMSELF. AND
HE COULD BE MISINTERPRETED AS
SOMEONE ON DRUGS OR SOMETHING
ALONG THOSE LINES AND SO MY WIFE
AND I CREATED A SAFETY NET AND
WE HAVE SIXTEEN THOUSAND
FAMILIES AND PROBABLY EVEN.
SIX OR SEVEN THOUSAND IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT OUR MEMBERS
OF OUR ORGANIZATION AND WE MAKE
WEARABLE ID.
SEE IF THIS IS OUR.
YEAH DOT AND WE MAKE WEARABLE ID
WHICH I PASSED SOME EXAMPLES
AROUND. I AM AND I WE HAVE AS A
CARE GIVER CONTROLLED SPECIAL
NEEDS REGISTRY.
AND. SO IN OUR EXPERIENCE.
I SAFETY FOR PEOPLE WITH AUTISM
EPILEPSY IS A THREE WAY STE
THREE. HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU
HAVE FAMILIES WITH PEOPLE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND CARE GIVERS
AND YOU HAVE THE GENERAL
COMMUNITY.
AND IF THERE'S A WAY FOR
EVERYONE TO KNOW THAT THIS IS A
PERSON THAT HAS SPECIAL NEEDS
WHEN THEY'RE MISSING OR CAN'T
COMMUNICATE IN A CRITICAL
SITUATION.
AND IT REALLY PUTS PEOPLE ON
THERIGHT PAGE AND GET PEOPLE
HOME
SAFELY. AND SO WE HAVE ABOUT AN
A SIXTY DIFFERENT PRODUCTS OF
WEARABLE ID BECAUSE EVERYBODY
HAS DIFFERENT SENSORY NEEDS.
AND MY SON FOR INSTANCE IF HE
GETS AWAY FROM HIS CAREGIVER.
AND WE NEED PEOPLE TO KNOW
IMMEDIATELY HE NEEDS HELP. SO HE
HAS A PATCH ON EVERY SHIRT. AND
SO I THAT WOULD HELP ON YOU KNOW
PEOPLE KNOW THAT HE'S A PERSON
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS IT ALSO WOULD
HELP BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. BECAUSE
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS SECONDS TO
MAKE A DECISION AS YOU KNOW
BETTER THAN I ON WHAT TO DO
ABOUT A SITUATION. SO IF THEY
SEE SOME SORT OF VAN I'VE YOU
KNOW ID ON SOMEONE SOMETHING
THAT THAT MAKES THEM THINK ONE
THAT MAYBE THIS IS A PERSON THAT
HAS SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND WHILE PROTECTING THEMSELVES
BECAUSE OFFICER SAFETY IS FIRST
PRIORITY.
THEY COULD.
PERHAPS APPROACH SITUATION IN A
MORE KNOWLEDGEABLE WAY IN AND
CREATE MORE POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
AND SO WE AND ALSO A LOT OF ARE
SAFE AYE SUCCESS STORIES
HAPPENED ON BEFORE IT GETS TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WHEN A KID GOES
MISSING IN A WALMART OR AND OR
ON THE STREET. A COMMUNITY
MEMBERS A FINING PEOPLE AND AND
THEY'RE SCANNING OUR PRODUCTS
AND GETTING HOME WITHOUT
POLICING BEING CALLED.
AND.
SEE HOW DID I MAKE THAT SLIGO
THERE WE GO. AND WE ALSO HAVE.
A SPECIAL NEEDS REGISTRY THAT'S
CARE GIVER CONTROLLED AND
THERE'S THREE PARTS TO IT THE
FIRST PART IS.
I'M A PUBLIC PROFILE SO IF YOU
SCAN ONE OF OUR PRODUCTS AND YOU
WOULD SEE ON YOUR SMARTPHONE
EXACTLY WHAT THAT PARENT OR
CAREGIVER ONCE YOU TO SEE TO
HELP THEIR CHILD AND GET THEM
HOME. AND MOST OF OUR STUFF ALSO
HAS A TELEPHONE NUMBER AND STUFF
ON IT SO THEY CAN BE CALLED
DIRECTLY.
THERE'S ALSO AN EMERGENCY
QUESTION AND ANSWER SECTION ON
WHICH IS THE TYPE OF THING THAT
AN OFFICER WOULD ASK INTO A
CRITICAL MISSING. AND SO THIS
CAN BE FILLED OUT IN REAL ITS
ACT BEFOREHAND AND DOWN
IMPRINTED IN KEPT IN A PERSON'S
PURSE OR EMAILED IN AN
EMERGENCY.
SO THAT.
IF BOND IF THEY'RE LEVEL OR
MISSING AYE THE INSTEAD OF LIKE.
STILL NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO
THEY COULD HAND THE OFFICER THE
INFORMATION AND THEY KNOW HEIGHT
WEIGHT AND HOW TO HELP PEOPLE
AND STUFF LIKE THAT. WE ALSO THE
THIRD PART TO OUR I CAN GIVE A
CONTROL REGISTRY WHICH IS A
NEIGHBOR ALERT. WHICH IS LIKE A
FLYER THAT YOU COULD PRINT OUT
IN ADVANCE AND GO TO YOUR
NEIGHBORS. AND SAY HERE'S MY SON
OR DAUGHTER AND THEY HAVE ON YOU
SPECIAL NEEDS IF YOU SEE HIM ON
THE STREET. AND THIS IS HOW YOU
CAN INTERACT WITH THEM AND
PLEASE CALL US HERE'S A
TELEPHONE NUMBER.
BUT THAT'S THE SECOND PART OF
THE REGISTER RIGHT THERE.
HERE'S THE HELLO NEIGHBOR ALERT.
AND EVERYTHING'S UPDATABLE IN
REAL TIME.
AND I WOULD TRY TO MAKE THINGS
INCREDIBLY EASY FOR PARENTS
SO THAT A LOT OF THE STUFF IS
JUST SET IT AND FORGET IT.
I THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE THAT DO
SIMILAR THINGS AND AND THAT'S
REALLY GOOD BECAUSE AND I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY SHOULD CORNER THE
MARKET IN THIS TYPE OF THING SO
THE PARENTS UPDATED OR DOES THE
ORGANIZATION UPDATED IN THE
PARENT STILL OKAY AND WE HAVE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH VARIOUS LAW
ENFORCEMENT ROUND THE COUNTRY
JUST ARE WORKING WITH ON THE NEW
YORK CITY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
AND WHERE MAKING.
A BIG ORDER FOR THEM WITH THEIR
LOCAL LINE AND STUFF LIKE THAT
SO I JUST MISSION WHETHER IT
STATEWIDE MORE SPECIFICALLY HOW
MANY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ARE AWARE OF THE PROGRAM.
AND WE WE AND TRAIN FOURTEEN
HUNDRED CHP OFFICERS AND LAST
YEAR IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I
END WHERE A VENDOR AND WITH THE
INLAND REGIONAL CENTER AND I
AND.
SEEMED PRETTY NEATO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES AND AND
THEY'VE BEEN SHARING OUR
INFORMATION WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
THERE. AND SO WERE MAKING SOME
STRIDES.
AND SO I. I ONE OF THE THINGS I
WAS THINKING WHEN I WAS DOING
THAT I TRAIN WITH MY WIFE ERIN
WHO'S. BASICALLY OUT OF IRAN
SHE'S THE BRAINS ON THE
TECHNICAL GUY.
SHE CAN SHE COMES UP WITH ALL
THE PRODUCTS
I AND IT MAKES ALL THE CONTACTS
AND SOCIAL MEDIA AND STUFF LIKE
THAT. AND SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING
OF THE SIEGE P. I WAS THINKING.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE SEEING SO
MANY THINGS ABOUT. EACH PERSON
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS IS DIFFERENT
SO WHAT WORKS WITH ONE. WON'T
WORK ON ANOTHER ONE MIGHT WORK
WITH ANOTHER. AND YOU KNOW SO
WE'RE SAYING YOU DO THIS AND
THIS AND THIS EXCEPT YOU KNOW IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK. AND SO WHAT
WOULD I DO FOR THAT AND I WAS
THINKING. AND IF I WERE AN
OFFICER AND I WOULD GET
PERMISSION IT TO GOING UNIFORM
TO PLACES WHERE THERE ARE SPENT
BEFORE SPECIAL NEEDS.
SCHOOLS AND GROUP HOMES SPECIAL
OLYMPICS AYE THERAPY SESSIONS SO
THAT I COULD SEE HOW PEOPLE THAT
ARE AROUND PROVIDERS INTERACT
WITH PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND SO THAT IF I SEE SOMEONE IN
THE STREET I I MIGHT THINK WELL
THAT'S SORT OF LIKE THIS GUY SAW
THAT TIME IN THEIR THERAPIST
SAID. IN A BRIEF.
BREED WITH ME YOU KNOW READ MY
LIPS OR OR YOU KNOW IS IT
WHATEVER THEY MIGHT HAVE SEEN
THAT MIGHT BE EFFECTIVE. AND
LAID OUT AND SO THEY WOULD HAVE
SOME TOOLS AND ALSO THE PEOPLE
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS IF THEY WERE
USED TO SEEING. OUR OFFICERS IN
UNIFORM COME TO THEIR SCHOOLS IN
THE PLACES WHERE THEY LIVE.
IF THEY WERE MISSING DATE MIGHT
TEND TO GO TO A POLICEMAN IF
THEY SEE IF THEY'RE LOST I'M
LOST I NEED TO GO TO A
POLICEMAN.
AND WHEN THEY SEE A POLICEMAN
THERE WOULD THINK WOW THIS IS A
FRIEND THIS IS SOMEBODY I CAN
TRUST BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS NOW.
AND TOO MANY TIMES IS THAT.
PEOPLE SPECIAL NEEDS AND THINK
THAT THE POLICE OFFICERS A
STRANGER BECAUSE MAYBE THEY
HAVEN'T MET. MANY POLICE
OFFICERS AND SO WHEN THE AND
WHEN SOMEONE'S LOOKING FOR
SOMEBODY LAST
AND THEY COULD BE HIDING.
AND SO IF THEY ON AND THEIR
VINCENT YOUNG DEATHS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT AS A RESULT SO IF I
SPECIAL NEEDS PERSON FIVE.
POLICE TO MY FRIENDS AND IF A.
IF AN OFFICER AND HAD A LOT A
LOT MORE EXPERIENCE I JUST BEING
AROUND PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
AND IT COULD BE A LOT OF.
INC YEAH EASY AYE EASY POSITIVE
OUTCOMES AND DOWN PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T.
TRAUMATIZED AND DIE GOOD
STORIES AND AND.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD BE AN
EASY WAY TO GET GOOD RESULTS.
I GUESS THAT'S IT. ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THAT'S GREAT I WAS NO WHERE
YOUR PROGRAM IT'S.
.
I LIKE IT HOW THANK YOU LIKE WE
ALSO HAVE A THING THAT WHERE I'M
TALKING TO THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ABOUT. AND THAT I
WAS TALKING TO AND I SENATOR
WILKS OFFICE AND I WAS ARE
SENATOR. AND I THAT IT'S IT'S
ALL TOO EARLY TO REALLY GET INTO
THE DETAILS BUT IT COULD BE S..
I STATEWIDE MISSING PERSONS
DATA BASE THAT ON. AYE EVERYBODY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO INTERACT WITH
SO AND I HOPE I'M NOT JUMPING
THE GUN TOO MUCH BY SAYING THAT
MUCH BUT IT'S IN THE WORKS GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU COVERING
FOR NEXT SPEAKER IS.
.
COULD BE AFTER THE*
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT.
AFTER UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY.
AND SERGEANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BUT MR ZERO.
TYPICALLY UPS MEMBERS PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
MORNING THE MORNING AND SO I AM
ASTRAZENECA AT THE EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKING LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY.
AND ON BEHALF OF MY UNION AND MY
SON MYSELF.
I LIKE TO THINK EVERYONE WHO IS
PARTICIPATING TODAY. ESPECIALLY
CHAIRMAN COOPER.
AND THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO WILL HOPEFULLY BE HER SOME
TO HEAR THE REST.
AND IS THIS IS BY NEARLY A TWO
YEAR LONG. JOURNEY FOR ME.
TO BRING EVERYONE TO THE TABLE
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
WITH THAT SAID THOUGH THAT MAY
GIVE JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON WHAT WHAT BROUGHT
US HERE TODAY.
SO.
UW REPRESENTS OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CAREGIVERS WHO PROVIDE
FOR LOW INCOME SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. AND.
I AM ONE OF THOSE CARE GIVERS
ASK. I CARE FOR MY OWN ADULT SON
WHO IS.
AUTISM AND INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY HIS NAME IS MANUAL.
AND A. MANUAL IS AT THAT SEVERE
AND OF THE SPECTRUM.
WHICH COMES WITH A MULTITUDE OF
DELAYS.
ABILITIES AND DISABILITIES.
HI HEAR IS NON VERBAL A VERY
VOCAL AND I HE IS PRONE TO
AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIORS.
I DOESN'T FOLLOW VERBAL COMMANDS
HE HAS NO FEAR OF WATER HEIGHTS
CARS.
AND AND YOU WANDER OFF AND AND
IF UNSUPERVISED
SO IT HAS HAPPENED.
UNFORTUNATELY.
BUT THAT'S JUST A PART OF WHO
MANUAL IS.
HE LOVES MUSIC I ESPECIALLY NOR
JONES AND BEETHOVEN. AND HE
LOVES HIS TABLET
HE LIKES TO WATCH. DOOR THE
EXPLORER.
BLUE'S CLUES DISNEY MOVIES.
AND HE'S VERY CHILDLIKE.
BUT HE LOOKS LIKE AND HAS THE
STRENGTH OF A YOUNG MAN.
AND THAT'S A DANGEROUS
COMBINATION UNFORTUNATELY.
FOR HIM LIKE ALL HUMANS.
WHO WE REACTS WITH A FIGHT OR
FLIGHT INSTINCT?
?
ESPECIALLY FILLED IF YOU FEEL
FRIGHTENED OR ENDANGERING YOU
ARE UNKNOWN TO WHAT'S COMING
ACTUAL. AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
HAVE ALWAYS WORRIED.
ABOUT HOW LONG FOR SENATE AND
OFFICERS ARE ANY FIRST RESPONDER
FOR THAT MUCH WOULD REACT TO HIM
AND HIS BEHAVIORS.
AND. THERE ARE SOME VERY REAL
SCENARIOS OF HOW THAT COULD
HAPPEN HE COULD WANDER FROM HIS
DAY GREW.
SOMEONE TO FEEL THREATENED
BECAUSE OF HIS SIZE AND HIS
BEHAVIORS ARE HIS ACTIONS AND
MAYBE CALL THE POLICE.
OR HE COULD HAVE A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY.
IN THOSE CASES MANY WOULD BE AT
THE MERCY OF WHATEVER TRAINING
OR LACK OF TRAINING.
.
THAT A FIRST RESPONDER MIGHT OR
MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD.
WOULD DEALING WITH PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES OR
MENTAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL FOR ANY
CASE.
I AM.
BUT FIRST OR FOREMOST I'M A MOM.
SO AND I HAVE SEEN TOO MANY
STORIES TO SIT BY AND I ONLY
WISH.
AND FOR MY SON TO BECOME ANOTHER
STATISTIC AND. MY FELLOW UAW
MEMBERS FEEL THE SAME WAY AND
MANY OF OUR CLIENTS SUFFER FROM
DISABILITIES FROM ALZHEIMER'S
DEMENTIA TO PTSD SCHIZOPHRENIA.
AUTISM CEREBRAL PALSY YOU NAME
IT.
AND THEY'RE WIDELY
MISUNDERSTOOD.
THEIR BEHAVIORS ARE ACTIONS OR
LACK OF ACTIONS MAY BE
INTERPRETED AS BEING DEFIANT HER
DRUG INDUCED.
WHERE AND WHEN FACT IT'S PART OF
THEIR DISABILITY OR MAYBE LACK
OF MEDICATION THAT THEY SHOULD
BE ON?
I'M IN THIS IS WHY WITH THE
SUPPORT OF MY UNION I HAVE SET
OUT TO FIND.
PART OF INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE OUR.
LEGISLATORS LIKE YOURSELF.
AND DEPARTMENTS THAT NO THAT
THERE MUST BE A BETTER WAY TO
EDUCATE TRAIN. UP FIRST
RESPONDERS AND NO.
WE CAN CREATE BETTER ALERT
SYSTEMS AND TOOLS TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE MET MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE PARTNERED
WITH SENATOR BILLS OFFICE ON SB
ELEVEN SP TWENTY NINE. BE
MANDATED TRAINING AND BILLS
WHICH I BELIEVE WILL GET A
UPDATE ON LATER ON THIS HAVE.
THIS MORNING. ON THE FOLLOWING
YEAR WE PARTNERED WITH SENATOR
GALGIANI IS OFFICE ON THIRTEEN
THIRTY WHICH WAS THE BILL THAT
CREATED THE INCLUSION OF THOSE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
TO BE CONSIDERED AT RISK WHEN
NEED BE ON THE LOOK OUT SCHOOL
OUT.
AND IN THAT SAME YEAR SENATOR
GALGIANI ALSO CARRIED A YEAR ARE
RESOLUTION ADOPTING THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER AS SILVER LURKED AND
COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS MONTH.
THIS WAS NECESSARY AS MOST
PEOPLE HAD NO CLUE WHAT A SILVER
LAKE IS.
OR THAT IT IS EVEN BEEN EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE ALL ADULTS WITH SOME
SORT OF COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT I'M
I BELIEVE WE'LL BE HEARING
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT LITTLE BIT
LATER ON TODAY AS WELL.
MOST RECENTLY WE WORKED WITH I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ IS
OFFICE ON A BEFORE THIRTY SEVEN.
WHICH WAS TO CREATE A STATE
WIDE.
DATABASE.
VOLUNTARY DATABASE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES
I'M THE AIM OF AB PRO FOR THIRTY
SEVEN WAS TO PRO ACTIVELY
PROVIDE VITAL INFORMATION AS
THE.
IF I NEED HELP PROGRAM DOES. AND
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WITH THE
INTENT TO EXPAND IT TO ALL FIRST
RESPONDERS.
I AM THE MAIN FOCUS WAS TO
POSITIVELY ENHANCE THESE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN LAW AND THE
COMMUNITY. ON THIS BILL BECAME A
TWO YEAR BILL.
AND DURING THAT TIME WE HAVE HAD
MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. UP AND DOWN THE
STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ARE RESEARCH IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS FOUND SEVERAL
OTHER STATES WHO HAVE INTRODUCED
SIMILAR LEGISLATION.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY WE FOUND
THAT THERE ARE MANY
MUNICIPALITIES AND DISABILITY
ORGANIZATIONS HERE AND STATE
CALIFORNIA. ALREADY ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES
AND IMPLEMENTING PROGRAMS ON A
LOCAL LEVEL.
SO IT SEEMS OBVIOUS THAT THE
MOST.
MOST EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE PLAN
WOULD BE TO EXPAND THESE EFFORTS
INTO ONE STATE WIDE COHESIVE
PROGRAM.
THAT WAY WHEN YOU ARE SOMEONE
ELSE TRAVELS WITH YOUR LOVED ONE
THE INFORMATION YOU INITIALLY
PROVIDING YOUR OWN LOCALITY.
WOULD BE AVAILABLE ANYWHERE IN
THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE.
IF I PROVIDE MY SON MANUALS
INFORMATION MODESTO WHERE I
LIVE.
AND WE TAKE A TRIP TO DISNEY
LAND OR SEA WORLD AND HE GOES
MISSING.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE FIRST
RESPONDERS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT INFORMATION.
NOT JUST IN HIS OWN AREA BUT
ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M IT WOULD ACCEPT EXPEDITE THE
RESPONSE TIME AND POSSIBLY SAVE
MY SON'S LIFE.
AS IT IS NOW THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR CONVEYING INFORMATION ON
MANUALS FALLS INTO ME. HIS
MOTHER.
WHO WOULD UNDERSTANDABLY HE
FRANTIC TRYING TO REMEMBER
EVERYTHING?
AND. LET ME JUST SAY.
TELL YOU I INDIVIDUALS LIKE MY
SON CAN'T WAIT
FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. TO COLLECT INFORMATION
BEFORE AN ALERT IS ISSUED OR THE
BE ON THE LOOK OUT FOR ISSUED.
MY SON CAN BE DROWNING IN A POOL
OR A RIVER IN A MATTER OF
MINUTES BECAUSE HE HAS NO FEAR
THAT WATER.
ASSEMBLY WHERE I'M MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND I DECIDED TO PULL
AB FOR THIRTY SEVEN. I'M SO I'M
NOT GIVING UP AS I'VE SAID MANY
TIMES. AND. NOW THAT THESE
ISSUES ARE OUT THERE THE MANY
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD TO MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT SOMETHING WILL
HAVE TO HAPPEN. THEM AND TODAY
YOU'LL HEAR THE STEPS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING TAKEN AND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND OTHERS FIRST
RESPONDERS THE TOOLS THAT THEY
NEED TO PROTECT PEOPLE LIKE MY
SON MANUAL.
AND THEMSELVES RIGHT THEY GET
TO GO HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES OUR
LOVED ONES GET TO GO HOME TO
WHEREVER THAT HOMEY DE.
I'M MY HOPE IS THAT AFTER
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE READY TO
START THINKING ABOUT.
THE VOICES IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
ARE OFTEN. ON HEARD AND HOW WE
CAN REACH OUT TO THEM. AND I
HOPE WE WILL WALK AWAY FROM
TODAY READY TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND DO THE WORK
NECESSARY. ON WITH THAT I I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
COOPER.
AND YOUR OFFICE FOR HAVING AN
OPEN DOOR AND LISTENING TO ME.
AND SEEING THE NEED FOR THIS
CONVERSATION AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM TO MAKING THIS HAPPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU AT
THE FIRST OF ALL PLEASE DON'T
GIVE UP ON A BEFORE THIRTY
SEVEN.
OBVIOUSLY IT WOULDN'T COME TO TO
YOUR BILL THERE'S SOME
RESISTANCE SOMEWHERE SO THAT
AMONGST THE MIDDLE HEALTH FOLKS
THEMSELVES ARE. NOW ACTUALLY I'M
MONEY.
YEAH VERY THAT THAT'S KIND OF
THE THE DEVIL'S.
KEY TO EVERYTHING IS AND HOW
MUCH WOULD IT COST
HOW WOULD IT BE IMPLEMENTED HOW
WOULD IT BE ADMINISTERED WHO
WOULD DO THE ADMINISTRATION OF
IT. I'M I'VE HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS MY ORIGINAL
LANGUAGE WAS FOR THE DOJ TO
EXPAND AND ENHANCE MAYBE ONE OF
THEIR DATA BASES THAT THEY
ALREADY HAD.
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION AND WHAT HAPPENED
WITH DOJ. AND.
THERE THAT WAS THEIR CONCERN IS
THEY COULDN'T FATHOM HOW THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO ADMINISTER OR
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED. ARM AND
THEN AND THAT'S WHEN WE DECIDED
TO GO AHEAD MAKE IT TO YOUR BILL
THAT WAS LAST SUMMER. AND AND
THEN I WENT ON MY RESEARCH AND
THAT'S WHEN I FOUND
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE AL DORADO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S WEB ON AUTISM
REGISTRY SANTA CLARITA. WHO
YOU'LL HEAR FROM OUT ROLES ON
SAN DIEGO WHO HAVE THESE THINGS
IN PLACE AND WE CAN TAKE BEST
PRACTICES FROM AND LEARN FROM? I
FOUND SEVERAL.
FEDERAL DOJ GRANTS DAD.
ADDRESSED EIGHTEEN BASED
PROGRAMS WERE ON INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
SO THERE THERE'S WAYS TO DO IT
WE JUST REALLY HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER TO PUT OUR. THINKING
CAPS
ON AND AND MAKE THIS HAPPEN
TOGETHER SISTER YOU KNOW WE DID
INVITE THE CALIFORNIA PARTNER
JUSTICE TO COME AND TALK ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY. OF A.
STATEWIDE DATABASE NAY REFUSED.
SO IT VERY INTERESTING.
SO THANK YOU THINK IT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
OUR NEXT SPEAKERS ARE LYNN
BOWLER DIVISION MANAGER SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR THE LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
STUFF ABOUT BEST PRACTICES
IMPLEMENTATION AND THEN SAN
DIEGO SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
TECHNICAL PROGRAM REGISTRY.
LIEUTENANT MIKE NOT.
HOPEFULY I SAID YOUR NAME RIGHT
MIKE.
THEN BUTCHER IT.
AND GOOD MORNING TO HAVE MY NAME
IS LYNN BULLARD THE SUPPORT
SERVICES MANAGER AT THE OAK
GROVE POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT
MEANS I HAVE I'M COMMAND
RESPONSIBILITY AUTHORITY OVER
THE DISPATCH NINE ONE ONE CENTER
FOR THAT AGENCY.
I'M I'M HERE TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT A PROGRAM CALLED
SMART NINE ONE ONE THAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AT THE OAK GROVE
POLICE DEPARTMENT HIT IS.
.
A TOOL THAT ARE CERTAINLY A
BENEFIT TO THE INTELLECTUAL
COGNITIVELY CHALLENGED COMMUNITY
BUT IT IS A PROGRAM.
THAT WE IMPLEMENTED FOR THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE
HOW TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT IT IT IS A REGISTRATION
TOOL. THIS PROACTIVE IT ALLOWS
SAID THE CITIZENRY TO DEVELOP A.
SMART NINE ONE OE PROFILE HE
AND THEY DO SO.
VOLUNTARILY.
THIS SMART NIGHT ON ONE PROFILE
ALLOWS MEDICAL FIRE.
INFORMATION THAT A CITIZEN AND
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE.
.
THE DISPATCH CENTER KNOW ABOUT
IN CASE OF AN EMERGENCY AND THE
SOLE GOAL HERE IS TO TAKE
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE IT TO RESPONDING UNITS
REAL TIME. SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE
RESPONSE.
AND US STRATEGIC DECISIONS WHILE
THEY'RE IN ROUTE TO EMERGENCY.
SO.
THE CITIZEN CAN PROVIDE AS
LITTLE OR AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
DESIRED ANOTHER VALUE OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM IS THAT IT'S
PORTABLE. WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT THE REGISTRATION
INFORMATION IS ENTERED INTO A
NATIONAL DATABASE?
SO FOR ANY COMMUNITY THAT HOW
SMART NINE ONE ONE IF I FOR
EXAMPLE GO ON VACATION TO
BOSTON.
AND I CALL NINE ONE ONE FROM MY
CELL PHONE MY NINE ONE ONE SMART
NINE ONE ONE. PROFILE WILL
DISPLAY IN THAT DISPATCH CENTERS
A NINE ONE ONE CENTER. SO NOW
THE INFORMATION THAT I HAVE
DEEMED VALUABLE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL FOLLOW ME
WHEREVER I GO. AND THAT THAT
PARTICULAR AGENCY CAN NOW USE
THAT INFORMATION AND I THINK
THAT THAT IS INVALUABLE. UP TO
THE GENERAL POPULATION BUT I
THINK IT'S ALSO INVALUABLE FOR
THIS PARTICULAR GROUP AND
POPULATION. YOU CAN PUT
PHOTOGRAPHS INTO SMART NINE ON
WINE AND THE INFORMATION IS
INSTANTANEOUS.
SO AM I WOULD LIKE TO SHOW AT
SMALLER SHORT.
AT A NEWS CLIP FROM ELK GROVE PT
WHEN WE IMPLEMENTED SMART NINE
ONE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS WELL.
ASSISTANT DEMONSTRATING.
HOW THE PRODUCT ISSUES?
YEAH.
WHAT IS? A FIRST RESPONDER TIME
DAYS.
ROAD USERS WITH YOUR CHILD SHOWS
IT'S WORKING.
THEN.
PREPARE FOR YOU IN AN EMERGENCY.
CANCER.
NINE ONE ONE CALLS.
THIS MESSAGE.
SAVE GETTING THE RIGHT
INFORMATION FROM.
YOU.
WHERE IS? THE LOCATION.
NINE ONE ONE.
HER OR NAMES ASSOCIATED WITH.
DO WE CALL
ONE ONE WERE ABLE TO SEE
ALLOCATED FOR THE SAKE OF.
OKAY XIN.
YOU WANT.
DO YOU HAVE YOUR FAMILY MATTERS
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
GET QUEUE
HERE AND
BETTER KNOWN.
EMERGING.
RESIDENTS SAY THAT INFORMATION.
SO IT'S RANTINGS OF.
NO.
WITH ME NOW.
A MISSING PERSON.
QUICKLY ACCESS.
AND REDUCE THE TIME.
OVERCROWDING. GETTING.
THE NORTH.
MASON.
WE ARE.
NO LEGAL OUR.
SO THAT'S A MEDICAL CONDITION.
THE RACIAL. TRANSFER OVER.
YOU KNOW CALL.
SURE THE INFORMATION TECHNICAL
INTERVIEWS WITH.
DURING AT.
THOSE YOU.
SO AM I WANTED TO TAKE AS.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
AND THE INITIAL CALL THE CAN.
SO I'M JUST
AS OUR BY NATURE A BIT CHAOTIC
THERE'S A LOT OF INFO.
I MEAN VERY QUICKLY THERE'S A
LOT OF I AM CURRENT
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES THAT ARE
GOING ON. DEBT HOW WE TALK WORK
FLOW A LOT WE TALK ABOUT HOW WE
GET THE INFORMATION AND HOW WE
MAKE IT MEANINGFUL TO.
.
TWO PATROL OFFICERS RESPONDED IN
THE FIELD BUT FROM A CITIZEN'S
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS THEIR WORST
DAY EVER.
THEY ARE ENCOUNTERING A
SITUATION THAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW THE MAGNITUDE OF AND
AND THEY MAY NOT IT.
KILLER TIME BUT. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY IN AN EMERGENCY
PERIOD BUT IT'S MORE DIFFICULT
AND PERHAPS EVEN IMPOSSIBLE. FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES I'M INDOSAT YOU
ASIANS WE MAY CREATE A CALL FOR
SERVICE AND THEN THAT POLICE
OFFICER IS GOING INTO THAT AB
SITUATION IN THE BLIND.
I AM NOT A POLICE OFFICER I AM
THE COMMUNICATIONS PROFESSIONAL
BUT I CERTAINLY CAN'T IMAGINE
GOING INTO A CALL FOR SERVICE
WITHOUT A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION TO MAKE A DECISION.
SO WITH SMART NINE ONE ONE AS
YOU SAW ON THE VIDEO THE
INFORMATION THAT I AM FROM THE
PROFILE IS DISPLAYED ON THAT
DISPATCHERS NINE ONE ONE SCREEN
AND IT IS DONE SO INSTANTLY AND
AUTOMATICALLY.
SO THERE'S NO NEEDFOR A
DISPATCHER TO QUERY ANY OTHER
SYSTEM
SUCH AS A STATE DATABASE IT
DISPLAYS IMMEDIATELY AND WE KNOW
THAT THAT INFORMATION HAS BEEN
VALIDATED WITHIN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS SO WE KNOW THAT THE
INFORMATION IS ACCURATE.
IF WE CAN CONTRAST THAT WITH AN
OFFICER GOING INTO A CALL IN THE
BLIND.
AND THIS ALLOWS THE DISPATCHER
TO MAKE MORE ACCURATE DISPATCH
DECISIONS THEY CAN TAILOR THEIR
QUESTIONS AND THEN DETERMINE
APPROPRIATE DEPLOYMENT BASED ON
THAT INFORMATION. WE ARE ABLE TO
SEND THE RIGHT NUMBER OF
RESOURCES TO THE RIGHT PLACE.
IT ALSO PROVIDES THE OFFICERS
THAT ARE RESPOND TO THAT CALL
CONTEXTUAL AWARENESS
THEY KNOW THAT THERE IS PERHAPS
AN INDIVIDUAL THERE THAT DAY YOU
WILL NEED TO RESPOND OR ADDRESS
IN A CERTAIN WAY. AND IT
PROVIDES THAT.
AGAIN ABILITY TO.
TO STRATEGIZE HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO DEAL WITH THAT CALL.
WITH INCREASE SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS AND THEY'RE ABLE. TO
RESPOND MORE SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY AND LESSENING THE
RISK FOR ALL.
SO I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT A
REAL LIFE SITUATION WHERE THIS
HAS BEEN USED IN THAT'S IN
ADDISON ILLINOIS. AT THAT
PARTICULAR AGENCY INVOLVED IN
NINE ONE ONE HANG UP CALL
SOMETHING THAT WE GET DAILY
HOURLY.
IN THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION.
THE PROTOCOL FOR MOST CENTERS
IS TO ATTEMPT TO CALL BACK BUT
FREQUENTLY WERE NOT ABLE TO MAKE
CONTACT. IN THIS SITUATION.
AT THE RESIDENT HAD A SMART
NINE ONE ONE PROFILE IN THAT
SMART NINE ONE ONE PROFILING
IDENTIFIED. THAT SHE HAD AN
ADULT SON WHO LIVED AT THE HOME
WITH HER HE AB WAS ARTISTIC AND
HE HAD A HISTORY OF VIOLENCE.
RESOURCES RESPONDED TO THAT
ADDRESS KNOWING THAT THEY MIGHT
ENCOUNTER AN INDIVIDUAL
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT TO
DISABILITIES WHO MAY BE VIOLENT.
OBVIOUSLY DOT PROVIDED A
VALUABLE MIND SET FOR THEM
RESPONDING I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS ACTUALLY INVOLVED
IN THE CALL THAT JUST KNOWING
THAT TO RESPOND IS.
PRICELESS DYEABLE INFORMATION
SO.
AS I'VE IDENTIFIED.
ELK GROVE HAS BEEN USING THIS
PRODUCT TIME I'M CERTAINLY A FAN
OF IT BUT WE HAVE HAD SOME
CHALLENGES.
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
ARE PRIMARILY BASED ON THE FACT
THAT WE ARE A SINGLE AGENCY USER
WITHIN A LARGER GEOGRAPHICAL
AREA SO ELK GROVE THE CITY ABOUT
PROBE IS ABOUT A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND POPULATION NOW
IT'S LOCATED IN THE SOUTHERN END
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY. AND WE ARE
LITERALLY AND I WENT INTO OF
OURSELVES BECAUSE OF BASS.
SO WHEN WE'D DO.
PROACTIVE REGISTRATION AND
CAMPAIGNS AND TALK TO PEOPLE
WE'RE TALKING TO APPROVE
CITIZENS AND ITS OAK GROVE
POLICE DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE GOING OUT THERE AND
ENCOURAGING US VOLUNTARY
REGISTRATIONS. SO WE HAVE WE DO
NOT HAVE THE.
ABILITY TOLEVERAGE A LARGER
AREA AND THEREFORE ARE AYE
REGISTRATIONS HAVE BEEN.
CERTAINLY DISAPPOINTING AND WE
HAVE DIED AT A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF.
OF OUTREACH AND TRYING TO
DEVELOP THESE SO THAT THAT IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE CONTINUE TO
CHALLENGER CONTINUE TO CHALLENGE
BY.
BUT TO COUNTER THAT THERE ARE
LARGE REGIONAL DEPLOYMENTS IN
THE COUNTRY FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE STATES OF ARKANSAS
DELAWARE IN MICHIGAN HAVE ALL
DEPLOYED SMART NINE ONE ONE.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE
IN THE CASE OF MICHIGAN AND THEY
HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH COMMISSION
THAT DID A STUDY THAT ACTUALLY
CHOSE SMART NINE ONE ONE TO TOOL
OF SMART I DON'T WANT TO BE
DEPLOYED. STATEWIDE AND THEY
HAVE THEY HAVE DONE SO.
ABOUT NINETY PERCENT OF THEIR
AGENCIES ARE NOW DEPLOYED A
CLOSER TO HOME IN KERN COUNTY
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING ON IT
EFFORT SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN.
DAY RECENTLY ENTERED INTO A FIVE
YEAR GRANT AND WHAT THEY FOUND
IS THAT DAY HAD A MUCH HIGHER
THAN AVERAGE NUMBER OF INCIDENTS
THAT INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS. WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES THAT
AT THE END OF AN INCIDENT THEY
HAD A HIGH LIKELIHOOD OF.
.
THE INCARCERATED OR
HOSPITALIZED.
AND WHAT THEY DID WAS BEGAN A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THAT
INVOLVES ALL POLICE DEPARTMENT
SHERIFF FIRED NINE ONE ONE
CENTERS. AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND THEY BEGAN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT THAT
I TO DEPLOY SMART NINE ONE ONE
AND TO USE THAT REGISTRY
COMPONENT. BUT THE PROGRAM ALSO
HAS A TRAINING AND EDUCATION
TOOL AND IT PROVIDES A NEW SHIP
MENTAL HEALTH FOCUS THAT HAS NOT
BEEN DONE BEFORE.
IT THERE.
PROGRAMS STATES CLEARLY THAT
THEY ANTICIPATE AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THEIR GRANT.
THERE TO BE FEWER PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND ERECT AND
ARREST DUE TO THEIR REGISTRY
DATA.
AND ANOTHER COLLABORATIVE
COMPONENT OF THIS IS THAT DAY
RECOGNIZED THAT VOLUNTARY
REGISTRATION IS DIFFICULT TO
ACHIEVE. AND THEREFORE THEY
HAVE.
CREATED SPECIFIC BENCHMARKS IN
ORDER TO.
.
Q. OPTION IT DOESN'T HAVE A
BETTER SUCCESS IN THIS AREA FOR
EXAMPLE THEY HAVE INCLUDED
HOSPITALS IN THE REGISTRATION
PROCESS SO THAT WHEN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
OUR IN OUR HOSPITAL THEY CAN AND
COMPLETE A REGISTRATION AFTER
SMART NINE ONE ONE AT THAT TIME.
SO.
ENCLOSING I'M AN ABSOLUTE FAN
OF THIS PROJECT PRODUCT IN TOOL
I THINK IT IS A WONDERFUL.
VALUE TO ANY CITIZEN IN ANY
COMMUNITY BUT CERTAINLY.
CERTAINLY THOSE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES AND I
ALSO WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS AND TO
DISCUSS THIS VERY VALUABLE A
TOOL AND TOPIC WITH YOU TODAY.
THINK USE ANYBODY OUTSIDE OF
GROW TRIED TO USE THE OF GROWTH
NINE ONE ONE.
I WON SYSTEM CHRIS ARE AS FAR AS
THE.
.
SMART NINE ONE ONE USING WOULD
ALSO THE CITY TRIED TO USE THEIR
SIGN UP FOR IT. OTSIDE THE CITY
RIGHT THERE ARE SOME INDIVIDUALS
CHEST SO IF THEY WORK IN THE
CITY OF ALL GROWN BUT THEY SIDE
AND THEN THEY WOULD HAVE SOME
VALUE WITHOUT BECAUSE IF THEY'RE
COMING INTO ITS GEOGRAPHIC
BASED.
SO WHEN THEY CALL NINE ONE ONE
IT WOULD COME INTO OUR CENTER
BUT IF IT GOES INTO ANOTHER
CENTER THEY DON'T HAVE NINE ONE
ONE THERE ARE SMART NINE.
THEREFORE THAT DATA WILL NOT
DISPLAY.
SO.
SMART I DON'T MIND ISSUES
PREDOMINATELY ON THE EAST COAST
AND MIDWEST AND IT'S KIND OF
SLOWLY WORKING ITS WAY TO THE TO
THE WEST COAST AT THIS POINT I
HOPE IT WILL BE AS POPULAR HERE.
THANK YOU.
NOW BEFORE COLOR NEXT PHILIP
ALONE AGES MY COLLEAGUES MOVING
JIM FRAZIER COLLECTED SAY
UNEQUIVOCALLY IS THE BIGGEST
CHAMPION. OF THE SPECIAL NEEDS
COMMUNITY AND SPECIAL EFFECTS
HE'S BEEN INVOLVED FOR YEARS
AND.
HAS BEEN THAT YOU MISS ADVOCATE
SO MUCH MAKING COMMENTS MISTER
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
AND I GUESS I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH
AND THANK YOU FOR. YOUR CONCERN
ABOUT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY COMMUNITY  AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT I NO LONGER SEE IS A
VERY CARING.
ORGANIZATION AND I THINK THAT
ANYTIME WE CAN HEIGHTEN
AWARENESS ON HOW. WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT BOTH IN EACH IN
EACH FACET. OF THE WE CONTINUE
TO EDUCATE AND AND.
DEPART THE PROCESS OF SUPPORT
AND.
TRAINING OR WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
MAKE SURE THAT OF THE OFFICERS
ARE SAFE AND SOLVES THE DD
COMMUNITY.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU DOING THIS
OF THIS IS DONE UNPRECEDENTED I
CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH. YOU.
THOUGHT.
I'M ALSO GONNA CULP LE A KEPT
ROBERT LOUIS THIS TIME ALSO
AFTER THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT CYNICALLY
STATION
.
ME I THINK YOU. FOR HAVING ME
HERE MY NAME IS MICHAEL CANNOT
VEHEMENTLY TENET WAS SENT YOU
COUNTY SHERIFF. ON THE HAVE
SHARE OF GORE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
COME SPEAK WITH YOU ARE ON A
SYSTEM OF PROGRAM THAT YOU WE
RUN IN SAN DIEGO THAT'S ALL OF
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IT'S
REGIONALIZED OUT THEIR IT'S
CALLED TAKE ME HOME.
I THINK IT'S FASCINATING TO SIT
HERE AND LISTEN TO ALL THE
SPEAKERS NOT ONLY TO HEAR NEW
THINGS THAT WE'RE AWARE OF THAT
ARE TRULY OUT THERE. BUT LISTEN
TO PEOPLE THAT SPEAK WITH
PASSION LIKE ASTRID IN AND
CONNECTING WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND I THINK MISTER FRASER JUST
SAID IT'S.
CORRECTLY IS THAT THAT THIS IS
NOT ONLY SAFETY FOR MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY. BUT ON BEHALF OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE
RESPONDING THOSE TYPES BECAUSE
IT GIVES IN THAT.
CRITICAL INFORMATION THEY NEED
TO KINDA HELP THEM MAKE A GOOD
JUDGEMENT WHEN THEY FIRST ARRIVE
ON SCENE.
WANT TO TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT A
BRAIN HAREBRAINED HERE IT IS THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT BROUGHT ME HOME
TO SAN DIEGO COUNTY. ON HIMSELF
WAS OF POWER MORE POLICE OFFICER
AND HE WAS RETIRED HE IS THE
FATHER OF A CHILD WITH AUTISM
WHO IS ON THE LOWER END OF THE
SPECTRUM. IS RESPOND TO THESE
TYPES OF CALLS WHILE WHILE
WORKING IN THE FIELD.
I'VE MET WITH BRIAN BRIAN AND I
HAVE GOING TO PRESENT TO TAKE ME
HOME TO DIFFERENT PARTS OF. OF
THE COMMUNITIES AND TWO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS HE SPEAKS VERY
PASSIONATELY.
HE KNOWS FROM A FIRST RESPONDER
STANDPOINT.
WHAT WE FACE AND WHAT WE LOOK
LOOK LOOK AT AND I THINK ASTRID
MENTIONED THE RESPONDING TO THE?
THAT'S CHILD THAT HADN'T GONE
LOST IN AND TO BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WHAT ARE
WHAT ARE WHAT IS OUR RESPONSE
POLICY WHEN WE GET ON SCENE WE
ASK A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS IN WE.
WE TRY TO GET A PHOTOGRAPH WE
SEARCH THE HOUSE IN THESE THINGS
TAKE TIME AND HE IS ALSO ONE
THAT I'LL TELL YOU THAT TIME IS
CRITICAL TO A TO A CHILD WHO HAS
NO FEAR. A CHILD WHO HAS NO FEAR
OF DARKNESS A CHILD WHO HAS NO
FEAR OF WATER YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
TIME TO PUT ALL THESE THINGS
TOGETHER AND THAT'S JUST NOT IT
SO. HE ACTUALLY HAD AN
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS CHILD GONE
MISSING.
AND BEING IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONDED
HE FELT.
THAT.
IN HIS WORDS HE SAID I'LL BE
HERE FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE
WITH MY CHILD MY CHILD I WILL
RAISE MY CHILD.
IF I CAN'T BE HERE WHEN HE NEEDS
ME THE MOST I WANT TO KNOW THAT
SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT ILL WILL
SOMEBODY THAT UNDERSTANDS OR
SOMEBODY WHO ADMITS THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
IN HIS LITTLE BRIAN'S WORLD
BECAUSE A LITTLE BRIAN. I WANT
SOMEBODY TO UNDERSTAND THAT SO
THAT'S WHY HE CAME OUT WITH THIS
REGISTRY LIKE TO SHOW YOU A
QUICK VIDEO.
REAL QUICK THAT WE PUT OUT IN
THE COUNTY.
YEAH.
YEAH. RIGHT HERE BEHAVIORS.
LITTLE LIGHT HAIRED THE
IMMENSELY COST A LITTLE THE
SAILORS.
HELLO IN THIS PARTICULAR THREE
HUNDRED.
EVEN BAG APPEARED ON WITH HAVING
YOUR.
I LOVE.
SEVEN EIGHT NINE.
YOU KNOW THE PHONE OUT OF THE
WORLD.
SMARTER THAN.
WE ARE.
LET LEGAL.
I ACTIVATED HERE A I DON'T WANT
TO PLAY BOTH WORK.
WELL. THAT'S CERTAINLY A ARE.
LEGAL MIND.
MARK.
IS A VERY.
BUT AS.
WITH MY WIFE.
THINK ABOUT IT WE REALIZED.
IT WAS REALLY
AND OFFERED HIM DONALD THE
FLORIDA CAN OF THE MEANS
YOU KNOW I WAS A VERY.
SO THIS YEAR.
NBAE.
THE VERSION
I REGISTRY.
MEMBERS OF THIS GROUP MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES
PROVIDE ACCURATE INFORMATION TO
FIRST RESPONDERS OR MEDIA NEEDS.
IN THIS REGISTRY HOLDS OUR
MEDICAL CONDITION SPECIAL CARE
INSTRUCTIONS A DETAILED
DESCRIPTION OF THE PERSON AND A
PHOTO. AND CURRENTLY.
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH.
ARE PROCESS RIGHT NOW IS AS
WITH PHOTO RECOGNITION SO WE
CONTACT SOMEBODY IN THE FIELD
THEY'RE UNABLE TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES WE'RE WORKING WITH
PHOTO RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY TO
COME BACK AND BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THAT PERSON.
IT'S CURLY SOMETHING OUR SYSTEM
HAS KEY CAPABILITIES OF DOING.
OUR REGISTRATION PROCESS BACK
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED WE HAD
CARE GIVERS.
HAD TO GO TO ONE OF ARE
STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATIONS ARE TO
A STATION TO REGISTER.
ON ANOTHER PROJECT I'M HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN ALZHEIMER'S SAN
DIEGO COUNTY HAS A HUGE PUSH
RIGHT NOW FOR ALZHEIMER'S LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE
ALZHEIMER'S.
AND AS PART OF THAT IN TALKING
THE CARE GIVERS WHAT I LEARNED
WAS IT'S NOT THAT EASY TO FILL
OUT A SIX PAGE FORM THEN GO DOWN
YOUR STATION AND SIT WITH
SOMEBODY AND WALK OVER IT. AND
DO IT.
SO I WENT TO OF THE SHERIFF AND
I ASKED HIM IF IT WAS POSSIBLE
WE CAN DO ONLINE REGISTRATION
AND.
HE FEELS TO PRIORITY TO CONNECT
WITH OUR COMMUNITY HE PRIORITIZE
WITH AN ORGANIZATION IN OUR DATA
SERVICES GUY.
INDIVIDUALS QUICKLY PUT
TOGETHER ONLINE REGISTRATION SO
NOW YOU CAN LOG IN ONLINE YOUR
IPHONE YOUR ANDROID DEVICE IN
YOU CAN FILL OUT AN APPLICATION
RIGHT THERE. YOU CAN STILL GO TO
A STATION.
TO REGISTER IF IF NEED BE WE
PREFER EVERYBODY REGISTER ONLINE
THAT WEIGHTS ATTACHED YOUR
USERNAME AND PASSWORD THE SYSTEM
IS ACCESSED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
ONLY AND IT'S A COUNTY WIDE
PROGRAM ACCESSIBLE TO ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I JUST FINISHED.
HOME OR RECENTLY THIS YEAR I
JUST FINISHED UP PROBABLY A TWO
YEAR TOUR OF EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WE ALL HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SAME DATABASE IT'S CALLED ES DE
LA. AND THROUGH THAT ES DE LAWS
WHERE THE REGISTRY FOR TAKE ME
HOME IS HOSTED.
SO WE ALL HAVE ACCESS TO IT SO
AS A REGION WET WEATHER IN THE
CITY OF THE MESA THE CITY OF
CHULA VISTA CORONADO SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. WE ALL HAVE THIS
INFORMATION.
HOW MANY CITIES OF JUST PUTTING
ALL THE CITIES IN THE COUNTY ARE
MOST?
SO.
AT THAT CITIES ARE WE HAVE ALL
OF THEM ONBOARD RIGHT NOW WE
JUST FINISHED WAS SENDING A P.
WHICH IS THE SECOND LARGEST.
AND WE HAVE LIKE HARPER PT SOME
OF THE SMALLER AGENCIES WHETHER
BE SOME OF THAT THE. FLAT
CASINO.
TRIED POLICE SINCE THE BIKE
THAT THEY'RE NOT ON BOARD YET
BUT WE HAVE ALL THE MAJOR CITIES
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY ON NOW
EDUCATED ON THE SYSTEM AND WHAT
IT IS.
SO HOW IT WORKS.
AN AND THIS HAS TO GO WITH US
WE ALL SHARE THE SAME DATABASE
WHEN YOU REGISTER ONLINE IT GOES
TO SAN DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. AND CRIME PREVENTION
SPECIALIST REVIEWS THAT
INFORMATION FOR ACCURACY AND
THEN THE INPUT IT. AND WHAT THAT
INFORMATION DOES IT THEN GOES
INTO SD LAW. AND THEY SEND US
EMAILS BACK WITH SOME CRITICAL
INFORMATION AND A PHOTOGRAPH AND
WE ATTACH IT TO OUR CAD SYSTEM
OUR CAD SYSTEMS COMPUTER
AUTOMATED DISPATCH.
THE CARS NOWADAYS ARE ALL
COMPUTERS LA LAPTOPS IPHONES. ON
SO WHEN YOU HAVE THAT CALL FOR
HELP BEGETS FLAG IN OUR SYSTEM
AS THAT INDIVIDUALS AND TAKE ME
HOME IT BECOMES A PRIORITY.
AND THEN OUR DISPATCHES ALLOWED
IT SENDS IT OUT TO THE VEHICLE
AND IT HAS CRITICAL INFORMATION
THAT GOES OUT TO THAT VEHICLE IN
DC. THAT INFORMATION THAT THAT
DEPUTY NEEDS TO KNOW IS IS
RESPONDING AND I'LL SHOW YOU A
SNAPSHOT HERE.
IT CONTAINS DEMOGRAPHICS A
PHYSICAL DESCRIPTION A
DIAGNOSTIC AND SPECIAL
CONSIDERATIONS AND ALSO THAT
PHOTOGRAPH.
AND AS I SPOKE OF EARLIER IF WE
MAKE A FIELD CONTACT WITH YOU IF
WE JUST COME UPON YOU IN THE
FIELD. WHERE IT THAT SEEM
DATABASES SEARCHABLE THROUGH THE
DISPATCH CENTER WITH NUMEROUS
INFORMATION HAIL MATS ONE TWO
THREE ANYTIME DRIVE CAN YOU TELL
ME? WITHIN THIS RADIUS HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE REGISTERED TAKE ME
HOME I HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL HERE
HE SAYS HIS NAME IS THERE SO IT
SEARCHABLE THAT WAY. AND ALSO
THROUGH THAT VOTER RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY.
SO WHAT TO GET OUT OF THE CAR
APOLOGIZE SMALL ON THE SCREEN
BUT IT COMES OUT IT LOOKS LIKE
THIS THIS IS AN ACTUAL SNAPSHOT
OF THE VEHICLE. ON THE SCREEN IN
A VEHICLE AND IT WILL GIVE THE
SPECIAL NEEDS INDIVIDUAL. AND TO
TELL THE DEPUTY WHAT HERE SHE
LOOKS LIKE THE NAME OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND ALSO AS YOU SEE
SPECIAL CONSIDERATIONS FEAR OF
DOGS HUGS NOISE SENSITIVE RUN
TENNESSEE OR WATER ATTRACTED.
AND THEN AUTOMATICALLY GIVES IN
THE PHOTOGRAPH IF IF ONE.
IS ATTACHED.
SO OUR PROJECT BENEFITS OF
COURSE OF THE SAFEGUARD THOSE
WHO NEED EXTRA CARE. ON SPEEDY
RETURN OF OUR LOS CLIENTES
SPEEDY RETURN TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO THE FIELD AND IT'S ALSO
REGIONAL ACCESS RIGHT NOW BY ALL
AGENCIES.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
ALLOWED ME TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR SYSTEM.
AND THAT'S AWESOME.
WHOSE AUTHORITY REGISTRY PERSON
LEGALLY.
BUT IT SO IT WOULD BE THAT THAT
CARE GIVER WE'VE AYE IT'S ALL
VOLUNTARY SO WE'VE GONE THROUGH
THE HIPPER CONCERNS IT'S ALL
VOLUNTARY THROUGH THE CARE GIVER
THAT HAS CONSERVING SHIP OVER
THE INDIVIDUAL. OKAY IN THE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
SOMEONE'S ENTRY AND SYSTEM.
AND WHO MAY NOT WANT TO BE IN
IT.
WE HAVEN'T RUN INTO ANY ISSUES
WITH SOMEBODY IN A SYSTEM THAT
IS GOING TO BE AND IT.
AND AYE MAGIC IF THAT WAS THE
CASE THEN WE WE COULD REMOVE
THEM. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE LEARNING AS WEAK AS WE GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS IS WHAT
YOU'RE IN THE SYSTEM IN YOU MOVE
HOW DO WE UPDATE THE SYSTEM
SOFTWARE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
POSITIVES PROS AND CONS WHAT.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO LEARN NOW
IS? IF THAT PERSON MOVES OR HOW
DO WE UPDATE THAT INDIVIDUAL A
HOW DO WE GET A MORE RECENT
PHOTO SO THIS IS THIS IS A
FAIRLY NEW THESE ARE SOME OF
THINGS WERE GOING THROUGH RIGHT
NOW TO TO LEARN TO WORK THROUGH.
HAVE YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
USE THE FACIAL RECOGNITION
SYSTEM AT ALL OR.
BUT I I KNOW IT'S BEING USED IN
THE FILM.
THERE ARE SOME GLITCHES IN THAT
SYSTEM ON AND ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE TAKE AWAYS FROM OUR OUR
SYSTEM IS WHEN WE WERE ASKING
PEOPLE FOR A PHOTOGRAPH THEY
WOULD. SEND US A PICTURE OF
THEIR MOTHER IN HER FAVOR LAZY
BOY CHAIR WILL BY THE TIME THAT
GETS OUT OF THE VEHICLE IT'S NON
USABLE. SO WE'VE ACTUALLY.
HAD TO CREATE AN IN OUR ONLINE
REGISTRATION WE DESCRIBE WHAT'S
LIKE A PASSPORT PHOTO SWEETIE
LIES THAT YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
IT'S STRICTLY AUDIENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEASE FACIAL
RECOGNITION A LOT TAKE SOMEONE'S
COMMITTED A ROBIN A BANKER. USED
A CREDIT CARD THE STORE THEY
HAVE GOOD CAMERA STE
YOU JUST TAKE THAT PHOTO AND RUN
IT. THROUGH AN OLD PERSON SYSTEM
AND AND MATCH IT'S I MEAN LAWS
THINGS WE USE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
THERE IS THE CRIMINAL SIDE CAN
BE APPLE.
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR THE DD
COMMUNITY EVERYBODY ELSE ASSIST.
SISTER HOW TO HOW TO MASH YEAH
MISTER FRAZIER QUESTIONS.
AMAZING SYSTEM THANK YOU OF
WHAT'S NEXT STEPS BECAUSE I MEAN
HE BELIEVES START ON THIS QUEST
SO. WE STARTED TWENTY TEN AND.
I WAS I WAS PULLED INTO A
COMMAND MEAN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
I WAS LAW ENFORCEMENT USUALLY
COORDINATOR FOR SAN DIEGO AND I
HAD SEARCH AND RESCUE TO
REGIONAL ASSET. AND I WAS GIVEN
THIS PROJECT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND I WAS I WAS TOLD BY COMMAND
WE ALL KNOW HOW THIS GOES THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE THIS FOR THE
REST YOUR LIFE SO. I'VE KINDA
HELD ONTO IT.
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE SYSTEM
I THINK INITIALLY WE INTRODUCE
STATE WE WE BLEW IT OUT THERE
AND THEN WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T PAY
ATTENTION.
SO IT'S A REAL COMMUNICATION
TOOL YOU NEED TO COMMUNICATE WE
NEED TO MAKE RELATIONSHIPS SO
I'VE GONE BACK THROUGH WITH ALL
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
REINTRODUCE IT. WE ACTUALLY ARE
STARTING WE RE INTRODUCING IT TO
OUR OWN DEPARTMENT EVERY COUPLE
YEARS YOU KNOW WHAT TURN OVER
NEW DEPUTIES AND STUFF WE TELL
THEM WHAT IT IS A. ARE YOU AWARE
THIS THIS IS WHAT IT IS WHERE DO
WE GO NEXT WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE.
CURRENTLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IS.
THE PHOTO RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY AND ALSO WHAT'S A BIG
THING IS THAT TIMELINESS OF OF
HOW CAN I GET YOU TO DO AN
ANNUAL UPDATE. CAN MY.
ONLINE REGISTRATION
AUTOMATICALLY KICK IT BACK
ALSO SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE'VE
DONE IN SAN DIEGO THAT CAME OUT
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S PROJECT BUT
IT'S ALSO WITH MISSING KIDS AT
RISK AS WE HAVE A LOOK SAN
DIEGO.
WHICH IS A COUNTY WIDE EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATION WILDFIRES THAT WE
HAVE IF YOU SIGN UP FOR A THINK
THERE'S OVER THREE OR THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
WELL WE WENT THROUGH AND WE
MODIFIED THAT TO TO BE ABLE TO
USE IT IF A MISSING CHILD WHO'S
AT RISK AN AUTISTIC CHILD GOES
MISSING. WERE ALLOWED TO USE IT
FROM THE FIELD SO IF FOR EXAMPLE
YOU'RE MISSING FROM AN ADDRESS I
CAN DO ONE MILE RADIUS AND IF
YOU'RE IN THAT ONE MILE RADIUS I
CAN ALERT YOUR PHONE WITH A
PHOTOGRAPH I CAN SEND YOU A TEXT
AND AN EMAIL. AND I SAID YOU
TOUCH THROUGH EMAIL WITH THE
PHOTOGRAPH THE INDIVIDUAL IS
MISSING WHAT HIS NAME IS AND WHO
TO CONTACT.
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE WE WE DO
WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND WE
CONTINUE TO GROW.
WITH MORE THINGS COMING BUT FOR
TAKE ME HOME RIGHT NOW I THINK
JUST TO REALLY GET US
PASSIONATELY WORKLOAD ONE GAP
THAT I'M UNABLE TO EXPLAIN. IS.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE REGISTERED AND I SPEAK TO
PEOPLE ALL OVER. AND I JUST
DON'T KNOW.
WHERE THAT GAP IS TO GET MORE
MORE PEOPLE REGISTERED I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THAT REGISTRY GROW
OF COURSE BECAUSE IT'S TO SUCH A
BENEFIT IN SUCH A GREAT
COMMUNICATION TOOL FOR US TO
REACH OUT TO MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION?
SO THAT'S SOMETHING I HAVE
TRIED TO ASK ABOUT SOME CARE
GIVERS WHAT WHAT WE MISSING
BECAUSE WILL DO A FAIR WILL DO
AN EVENT AND WE'LL GET A FEW
PEOPLE SIGNED UP. BUT ALL SPEAK
TO THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE AND YOU
KNOW AFTER.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WE HAD BUT
TO TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WITH
FIVE OTHER PEOPLE AND THEN AFTER
WE START REALLY TAKING A LOOK AT
IT PUSHING IT OUT. WE WENT UP TO
TWO THOUSAND SO HOW DO WE
CONTINUE THAT SO.
THAT'S WE'RE GOING THE PROGRAM
HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO KEEP IT
UPDATED AND ACCURATE. AND SO HOW
DO WE GET PEOPLE TO SIGN UP IT'S
VOLUNTARY ACCESS BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ONLY.
BUT HOW DO WE GET THAT WHERE'S
THAT MISSING PIECE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT UP IS KEPT IN THE LUIS FROM
I. REALLY COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
SO.
SURE COOPER NEVER ANY THANK YOU
FOR A HAVING ALL THIS YEAR TODAY
YOU I'M.
FRAZIER STAND UP WHEN I PRESENT
SO SITTING DOWN ALL THE MOVING
AROUND A LITTLE BIT SO.
MY NAME IS ROBERT LEWIS I AM A
OUR THIRTY THREE YEAR MEMBER OF
THE LAWSUIT CAN SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT I'M CURRENTLY
ASSIGNED TO SEE ANY CRITICAL THE
STATION.
SENATE CREEL ISSUES HAVE AGREED
ON THE COUNTY AREA SURROUNDING
SENATE CAREER UP.
IS HOME TO TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THREE THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
TWO HUNDRED OF ON FOURTEEN
THOUSAND WHICH ARE IN THE CITY
CENTER CREATED SEVEN I THOUSAND
WHICH ARE IN THE COUNTY.
IT'S A VERY.
VAST AREA.
THAT I DEAL WITH THEM A
PATROLMAN.
DEAL WITH. SOME OF GOING
THROUGH A QUICK CAR POWER POINT.
PRESENTATION AND THAT ALL BY
SPEAK FROM THE HEART I'VE HAD A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE AND IN SOME OF
THESE AREAS.
SO OF THE SPECIAL NEEDS REGISTRY
IN TWO THOUSAND.
BACK IT UP.
SO SPECIAL NEEDS REGISTRY.
AS A FREE SAFE TOOL FOR THE
PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO USE ITS
PRODUCT OF WAY FOR US IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
TO INTERACT WITH THE THE
COMMUNITY IN THOSE ARE IN
CRISIS.
SPECIALTIES REGISTRY YOU ARE
WERE DESIGNED TO THOUSAND THREE
BY DEPUTIES ARE WITH.
MEMBERS IN THE COMMUNITY WHO
HAD.
CHILDREN ARE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
ARE INDIVIDUALS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS INCLUDING ALZHEIMER'S AND
A BI POLAR.
BUT ASSIST US IN FINDING ALL LOS
PERSONS IDENTIFYING CON PERSONS
GET SUCH A MEDICATION.
INFORMATION AND GET IN TOUCH
WITH CARE GIVERS WHEN NECESSARY.
THE PROGRAM ITSELF IS.
LAWS TO INTERACT AND
COMMUNICATE WITH COMMUNITY HOW
CALM THE PERSON DOWN AND.
ACCOMMODATE THE PERSON'S US
SPECIAL NEEDS.
THE SPECIAL NEEDS REGISTRY FOR
SENATE CREE INTO THOSE LEVIN OF
WAS AWARDED BY THE CALIFORNIA.
ENERGY. SHE'S EMERGENCY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION AND ALSO.
BY FEMA.
HELP FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS
PARTICIPATE.
AS THE OTHER UP PROGRAMS YOU'VE
HEARD TO CREATE A SECURE ACCOUNT
ONLINE. OCCUR THE PROFILE
DETAILED INFORMATION INCLUDING A
A PHOTO THEY CAN PROVIDE.
PROGRAM IS NOW UPDATED ON A
YEARLY BASIS SO WE MAKE SURE AND
WE ENSURE THAT WE RECEIVE IN NEW
FOUGHT EVERY YEAR. TO UPDATE OF
THE PROGRAM.
TIMES.
DILAPIDATED.
AYE BUT IT'S AN A CHRISTIE'S
XIN FOR OVER THE COURSE MY THREE
THREE YEARS.
OUT MY THIRTY THREE YEARS ABOUT
TWELVE THEM OF THE YEARS OF MY
CAREER FROM DEPUTY TO.
LIEUTENANT AND NOW CAPTAIN.
SO WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE PHOTO
WE HAVEN'T GIVEN UP DID.
.
THE CAREGIVERS FUSS BILLY IS TO
RECEIVING CARRY A SPECIALIZED
REGISTRY ID CARD.
KEEP INFORMATION UP TO DATE AND
ADVISED UP THESE AND I DON'T
OPERATOR OF HE PERSON'S SPECIAL
NEEDS REGISTRY.
OTHER W. SO LONG GONE INTO THE
SYSTEM LIKE ISN'T SECURITY POINT
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ONCE IDENTIFY PERSONS FOUND.
THE INFORMATION IS CREATED
INSTANTLY AND IT PROVIDES
ACTUALLY A MISSING PERSONS FLYER
PRINTS ON MISSING PERSON FLYER.
WE CAN TRANSMIT THAT NOW
WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF MOBILE
DON'T DIGITAL COMPUTERS IN THE
FIELD. FOR THE COURSE OF THE
PAST EIGHT NINE YEARS OF THE
FLYERS CAN BE GENERATED BY A
SUPERVISOR IN THE FIELD. AND
THEN THE SUPERVISOR TO PRINT UP
IN THE FIELD FOR DEBBIE'S TO
DISTRIBUTE TO THE COMMUNITY OF
PERSONS MISSING.
IT'S.
.
INTERNET BASED IT'S A A SECURE
LOG AND LIKE I SAID ARMS MOVE
THROUGH A COUPLE THE SLIDES.
A QUICK.
THE KIND OF SHOWS YOU OF WHAT
THE DEPUTY SEE WHEN THE COME UP
OVER THE PROGRAM. ON THE
COMPUTER AND ON THE MOBILE
DIGITAL COMPUTER.
PERSONS FOUND ALL THE IN THE
REGISTRY SO.
IF WE FIND A PERSON WE CAN LOG
IN AND SEARCH TO FIND OUT THE
PERSON IS IN THE SPECIAL NEEDS
REGISTRY.
IT HAS ALL THE INFORMATION
THERE FOR THE JAPANESE TO BE
ABLE TO TO UTILIZE.
PROS AND CONS BENEFITS AND
CHALLENGES.
SO THE PROS IS SAVED UP THESE
ARE A COUPLE OF HOURS ONE THREE
HOURS TO GATHERING INFORMATION
FROM ALL OF ONE'S FAMILY
MEMBERS.
MEDICATIONS ARE PERSONS.
USUAL LOCATIONS AGO TOO PEOPLE
IDENTIFY OF SO SEIZE US HOURS IN
TIME.
ESPECIALLY CRITICAL DURING
MISSING PERSON.
PICTURE IT CREATES THE A MISSING
PERSONS FLYER. QUICKLY
IDENTIFIES A PERSON TO BE ABLE
TO REUNITE THEM.
DEPUTIES LIKE USEFUL INFORMATION
THAT IS VERY AYE USER FRIENDLY.
ACCOMMODATE IN IRAQ TO
EFFECTIVELY IS CD COMPLIANT.
SICK WE HAVE SOME SUCCESS
STORIES.
AUTOMATED OF REMINDERS UPDATE
EVERY TWO YEARS WE HAVE REDUCED
IT DOWN TO ONE YEAR.
SO.
WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
PROGRAM OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR. I REINTRODUCE IT NOW
WE REDUCED TO ONE YEAR SO THE
REMINDERS THAT YOU KNOW OUT TO
THE PARTICIPANT.
AS THAT WE'RE JUST
AUTOMATICALLY EVERY YEAR IT
SENDS NAME OFF THE PRODUCE
MINNOW UNDERSTAND IT'S AN AGREED
WE HAVE AREAS THAT OF. A LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPUTERS.
THERE ARE LOCAL LIBRARIES
ETCETERA THAT.
WE HAVE VOLUNTEERS TO GO AND
MEET ONCE A YEAR WE PUT IT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA WITH A NO COME DOWN
TO THE LIBRARY. RE REGISTER
YOUR.
YOUR LOVED ONE WE SEND OUT A
LETTER TO THE HOUSE.
SO THE CONCERT THERE ARE FEW
CONS TO IT AND THAT IS THAT THE
THE SOME OF THE OFFICERS OF THE
ROUTE TRAIN DON'T KNOW HOW TO
USE IT. SO THAT'S ALL THE THE
LITTLE INSULAR THINGS THAT I
DEAL WITH AS A MINISTER'S YOU
KNOW.
.
PEOPLE HERE DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT
WE'RE TRYING TO THE INFORMATION
OUT NOW WITH THE STRUCTURE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA OUR LOCAL.
PAPERS ARE ON BOARD WITH
GETTING THE INFORMATION OUT WE
REALLY START TO PUSH US IN THE
BACK AS CAPTAIN FOR THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF. RELEASED ARE
THE PUSH ABOUT SIX MONTHS AGO.
THAT'S MY SECOND SECOND I HAVE
MY FIRST YEAR BENCHMARK DRANK OF
THIS PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING BACK
OUT THE WAY IT SHOULD BE
UTILIZED. AT THE GROUND OUT ON A
TERRIFIC PATH.
WE NEED TO KEEP THE INFORMATION
UP TO DATE THAT'S AWESOME
BECAUSE IS TRYING TO REACH OUT
AND GET EVERYONE.
SO.
PROS OUTWEIGH THE CONS IT SAVES
LIVES IS PROACTIVE.
POTENTIAL FOR LINKING OF
REGISTRY JUST OVER LURKED FUND
CRITICAL MISSING.
ESPECIALLY DURING.
DROWNING ANOTHER.
DANGERS.
SO THE CITY SENATE FREDA IS THE
ONE WHO SPONSORS THE PROGRAM TO
SEE SANTA CRUZ OPEN SHARING
THEIR SPECIAL NEEDS PROGRAM%
TECHNOLOGY AT NO CHARGE.
SO.
THEN THE ISLAND DOES PICTURE
HERE SHE IS THE ONE THE START OF
THE PROGRAM WITH ME BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE WITH THE
DEPUTIES.
HER IN ON JUDGE WE MANAGE THE
PROGRAM.
THEY MANAGE IT.
THEY VOLUNTEER RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THEM A.
YEARLY STIPEND TO HELP MANAGE
THE PROGRAM TO MAINTAIN IT. I
GATHER ALL THE INFORMATION AND I
WILL GO OVER THE LAST SLIDE
BECAUSE IN THE PUT IN A PICTURE
OF ME AND I'M STAND IN FRONT OF
SO. THAT.
SO.
.
SO I'M THE SPEAK A LITTLE BIT.
THROWN FROM THE HEART WE HAVE
FLYERS OF THE PROOF PROVIDE TO
THE DEPUTIES ON THE FIELD IT'S
BOTH IN SPANISH AND ENGLISH.
THE DEPUTY PROVIDE THE FUEL THE
PRIOR PROVIDED TO THE RESIDENTS
TO BE ABLE TO LOG ON TO
REGISTER.
SO FROM THE CUP FROM FROM THE
HEART.
BEFORE I CAME TO SANTA CRUZ
STATION.
.
I WAS ASSIGNED TO ADVANCE
OFFICER TRAINING. CRAWL FOR A
PERIOD OF A YEAR AND A HALF.
ON BEHALF ASSURE FUDGE
MCDONNELL.
I KNOW THAT.
AND WE WERE TALKING EARLIER
ABOUT S. B. TWENTY NINE S. B.
ELEVEN.
SO WHEN ASTRID MISSION THAT I
CAN OF KEY TO ME. S. BETWEEN S.
B. ELEVEN I WAS PART OF THE
INITIAL.
START UP ON OUR DEPARTMENT FOR
CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING.
THE DEVELOPED PERSON RICH
COUNTRY PROGRAMS THREE TWO HOURS
FOR THE CANCERS DEPARTMENT. I
KNOW THAT THE.
.
STATE HAS DIFFERENT AS SOME
REQUIREMENTS BUT OUR REQUIREMENT
IS THIRTY TWO. AND WE RECENTLY
RECEIVED OUR A CERTIFICATION
TRIPLES FOR A THIRTY TWO HOURS.
AND HERE'S WHERE WHERE I COME
INTO PLAY THE SPECIAL NEEDS
REGISTRY NOT ONLY.
SHOULD DEAL WITH.
AUTISM ALZHEIMER'S BY POOR
ISSUED YOU ACROSS THE GAMUT WE
KNOW THAT ACROSS THE NATION.
.
THE PRESIDENT'S IDENTIFIED THAT
THERE WAS AN OPIATE OVERDOSE
EPIDEMIC.
SPECIALTIES REGISTRY WE'RE GOING
TO BE.
SEGUEING INTO ALLOWING PEOPLE
PARENTS YOU HAVE KIDS THAT ARE
DRUG ADDICTED TO HAVE DRUG
DEPENDENCIES TO BE ABLE TO LOG
ON TO THE SYSTEM. WHO PUT DOWN
THAT THEIR SON OR DAUGHTER WILL
BECOME A CONTACT WITH THEM?
HOUSE THAT SPECIAL NEED AS WELL
BECAUSE NOT ONLY SPECIAL NEEDS
OF OF.
.
IT'S SPECIAL NEEDS ACROSS THE
BOARD AND BUT THAT'S WHAT CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING DEALS
WITH.
THE THIRD CHARGE REALLY
IDENTIFIES.
FOR DEPUTIES ON OUR DEPARTMENT
ON HOW TO DEAL WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN THOSE
CRISIS.
THE SPECIAL NEEDS REGISTRY
CLOSES THE GAP AND CLOSES THE
CIRCLE BECAUSE THE DEPUTIES WE
CAN TRAIN THEM ALL WE WANT I CAN
TRAIN MY DEPUTIES FOR THIRTY TWO
HOURS ON HOW TO DEAL WITH THOSE
ARE IN CRISIS THOSE ARE ARE
DEALING WITH DRUG ADDICTION.
BUT WHAT WE WILL BE DON'T CLOSE
FOR THEM IS THE OTHER HALF IT
AND HOW TO IDENTIFY THEM IN THE
COMMUNITY. THIS REALLY KIND OF
CLOSES THE GAP.
SO ON BEHALF THE SHERIFF AND.
ONE THINK.
DOING. AND.
S. R. ASTRID.
PREV ME UP HERE TODAY BOB HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
WITH FRAZIER.
SO YOU GOT THIS PROGRAMS INTENT
WHO'S BEEN THERE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THREE TWO THOUSAND
THREE WAS DEVELOPED BY DEPUTIES
MYSELF IF YOU'RE THE DEPUTIES WE
CAME IN CONTACT WITH SOME
MISSING KIDS IN THE IN THE
FIELD.
AS YOU KNOW SOMETIMES WHEN YOU
DEAL WITH.
TEARS AND I HAVE SEVERAL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
.
PARTNERS THAT I WORK WITH.
HAT HAVE A SONS AND DAUGHTERS
WHO HAVE AUTISM.
AND WHEN YOU TOUCH ME ON THE
SHOULDER HE CREATES A DIFFERENT
REACTION IF YOU TOUCH ON THE
BACK OF CHRISTOPHER ACTUALLY
RELIES ON TWO THOUSAND THREE AND
ONE TO. CREATE A PROGRAM WHERE
WE COULD PUT THE INFORMATION IN
THERE TO DEPUTY. THAT'S BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE TWO THOUSAND THREE.
TOM THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THE
PROGRAM HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED BUT
I HAVE.
EVERY YEAR FROM THE CITY OF SAN
AGREED UP.
WE'RE GONNA BE UPDATING IT.
AND THE OTHER SET FORTH.
OF BUT THE PROGRAM FUNDING TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP THE PROGRAM DID.
THIS IS STRICTLY ONLY FOR SENATE
CAREER WE HAVEN'T.
REACH ACROSS TO OTHER.
STATIONS FOR OUR DEPARTMENT OR
LAPD THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM BUT PERCENT AGREE SENATE
CREUS CAP SLATED IN THE VALLEY
ITSELF INTO A RIGHT THREE
THOUSAND RESIDENCES IS
TREMENDOUS YOU CURRENTLY WE HAVE
ABOUT. ELEVEN HUNDRED AND VISUAL
CENTER REGISTRY.
SO AS FAR AS A TRAINING SPOKE
ABOUT THE THIRTY TWO HOUR THE
CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING FOR
A THAT DEPARTMENT WIDE. THIS
YEAR'S DEPARTMENT VERY TO OUR
CHRISTIAN IMAGERY WAS.
INTRODUCED BY SHERMAN DONALD
LEFT THE PROGRAM TOGETHER OF.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO HOURS CRESCENT WRENCH
TRAINING DEPARTMENT WIDE CAREER.
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ABOUT FORTY PERCENT OF OUR
PATROL PERSONNEL TRAINED AND SO
THE AUDIENCE KNOWS THAT IS
OPTIONAL TRAINING THAT IS NOT
MANDATED TRAINING.
THAT THEY CHOSE TO DO CORRECT.
IT IS OPTIONAL TRAINING BUT IS
IT'S OPTIONAL TRAIN BUT IT'S
MANDATED BY SHARPER TAL EVERYONE
THROUGH OUR IN OUR DEPARTMENT
CHAU GO THROUGH BUT STATEWIDE
INHALED TEA IS WHAT TWENTY FOUR
HOURS EVERY TWO YEARS IS A FORTY
HOURS I CAN'T MEMBERS.
IT IS.
TWENTY FOUR HOURSEVERY TWO
YEARS FOR CONTINUAL PROFESSIONAL
TRAINING CPT TRAINING OUR COURSE
INTERVENTION TRAINING ITSELF.
IT WORD A CRITICAL POINT NOW I
BELIEVE IN THE COMMUNITY FOR THE
DEBBIE'S NEED YOU TO RECEIVE IT.
SERVER DOLLARS ON THIS
IMPRESSION AND OR WERE TRAINING
ALL OF OUR PATROL PERSONNEL.
COURSE INTERVENTION TRAINERS
ALSO A THIRD YOU ARE CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING FOR JAIL
PERSONNEL WHICHIS A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM IN THE JAIL OUR
POPULATION THEY HAVE ALREADY
TRAINED CLOSE TO SEVENTY PERCENT
OF THE DEPUTIES IN IN THE JAIL
SWIVEL SPEAKER COMING UP VIA
TALK ABOUT TRAINING STATEWIDE
THAT'S THAT'S A. BIG ISSUE
BECAUSE YOU FIGURE EVERY LOT FOR
SAYING SEE OUR LOVE FOR
SLAUGHTER. GO THROUGH TRAINING
EVERY TWO YEARS TWENTY FOUR
HOURS MAY HAVE CERTAIN MANDATED
TRAINING SO IT'S IT'S LA IS
DOING SOMETHING UNIQUE. WHERE IS
WHEN YOU'RE IN TRAINING OVER
FOLKS OFFICER YOU GOT BACK FILL
BEHIND THEM SOMEHOW SOMEWHERE SO
IT IS VERY EXPENSIVE SO THERE?
TAKE UPON THEMSELVES TO DO THIS
TRAINING ABOVE AND BEYOND. WHAT
MOST FOLKS DO SO I I COMMEND YOU
DEPARTMENT OR SHARE OF? FOR
HAVING THE FORESIGHT TO DO THAT
BUT.
THE REALITY IS MOST APARTMENTS
WILL NOT DO
GOOD MORNING SIR GOOD MORNING.
UP FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING ON
SUCH AN IMPORTANT TO A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE.
I'M LIEUTENANT REGGIE WILLIAMS
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL'S
A ASSISTANT LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE.
HERE TO APPEAR ON BEHALF OF
COMMISSION WARNED STANLEY.
.
I WILL TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE.
SOBRE ALERT UM THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL'S ROLE AND.
ACTIVATING THE SOBRE ALERT.
SOME OF THE CRITERIA.
THAT'S ARE REQUIRED TO ACTIVATE
IT AND.
DISCUSS ALMOST TO SCHOOL
INFORMATION.
RELATING TO THE AT.
SOME OF THE.
ACTIVATIONS AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE RECOVERY EFFORTS.
SO BASICALLY THE US OVERLOOKED
PROGRAM IS MODELED AFTER THE
AMBER ALERT OF PROGRAM.
.
IT.
ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
BROADCAST.
AYE THE REGIONAL OR STATEWIDE.
ALERTS FOR AT RISK SENIORS OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE COGNITIVELY
IMPAIRED WHO GO MISSING
UNFORTUNATELY.
AND THEY MAY BE IN DANGER.
DUBBED THE CHP OF COURSE SERVES
AS THE STATEWIDE COORDINATOR OF
THIS PROGRAM.
WE WORK GO DIRECTLY WITH OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ALLIED
AGENCIES.
TO DETERMINE.
IF INDIVIDUALS MEET THE
CRITERIA AND OF COURSE WE
BROADCAST THE ALERTS OF SOME OF
THE CRITERIA OF COURSE
INDIVIDUAL.
B. SIX FIVE YEARS OF AGE OR
OLDER. OF THE ARE DEVELOP MILLIE
JUST DISABLED OR COGNITIVELY
IMPAIRED.
THE INVESTIGATING AGENCY HAS
UTILIZED ALL OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO LOCATE THE
INDIVIDUAL.
IT'S DETERMINE THE PERSON.
HAS GONE MISSING UNDER
UNEXPLAINED OR SUSPICIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT'S DETERMINE THAT THEY'RE IN
DANGER.
THERE MAY BE IN THE COMPANY OF.
INDIVIDUAL WHO.
WILL PLACE THEM IN DANGER.
OR OTHER FACTORS INDICATE THAT
THE PERSON MIGHT BE IN PERIL.
.
AND THERE'S INFORMATION
AVAILABLE THAT.
IF DISSEMINATED TO THE PUBLIC.
COULD ASSIST IN THE SAFE
RECOVERY OF THE MISSING
INDIVIDUAL.
.
SO WITH THAT.
ONCE WE.
.
RECEIVES INFORMATION VERIFY THAT
THE HAVE.
MET THE CRITERIA WE WILL.
ACTIVATE THE ALERT AND THAT.
ALERT WILL CONSIST OF EITHER
MESSAGES GOING OUT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
COMMUNICATION CENTERS THROUGH
CLIPS.
WEEKEND NO BROADCAST BE ON THE
LOOK OUT ALERTS TO THE AFFECTED
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS.
BUT THE ISSUE ALL POINTS
BULLETIN FLYERS.
AND IF THE YOU.
MISSING INDIVIDUAL.
ALSO INCLUDES A VEHICLE WE CAN
ALSO USE THE CHANGEABLE MESSAGE
SIGNS OF TO PUT THAT INFORMATION
OUT THERE.
OF COURSE SIX TWENTY THIRTEEN.
WE HAVE ACTIVATED OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED AND THE SILVER ALERTS.
AND.
OF THOSE.
AT LEAST OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WERE LOCATED
BY FRIENDS OR FAMILY MEMBERS.
THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY OR THEY JUST SIMPLY
RETURN ON THEIR OWN.
.
THE SEA EN MASSE WAS ACTIVATED.
FORTY NINE TIMES.
THROUGHOUT THOSE THE ACTIVATIONS
AND.
AT LEAST
FORTY SIX INDIVIDUALS WERE
RECOVERED AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
A SILVER ALERT ACTIVATION.
AND.
.
NOW THAT IN IN A YEAR PERIOD OR
THE ENTIRE TIME THE ENTIRE TIME
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN LET'S NOT
THAT MUCH REALLY.
ABOUT FORTY TO FORTY NINE.
SIX FOOT FORTY NINE TIMES WE
HAVE ISSUED THE.
CHANGEABLE MESSAGE SIGNS.
AND OF COURSE EVERY MISSING
PERSON DOES NOT OF ALL VEHICLES
LESS ON TIME WILL ACTIVATE THE
CHANGE WILL MESSAGE SIGNS.
BUT AT LEAST FORTY SIX
INDIVIDUALS LOVE WERE. WERE.
DEFINITELY RECOVERED JUST BASED
ON THE ACTIVATIONS OVER LEARN.
BUT YOU KNOW GENERALLY SPEAKING
OF THESE THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL
THE RETURN ON THEIR OWN.
OR FAMILY MEMBER WILL LOCATE
THEM IN A IN A FAMILIAR
LOCATION.
.
BUT.
YOU KNOW WE WE FEEL LIKE THE
SILVER ALERT IS AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL TO ASSIST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND. RECOVERING THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND RETURN THEM.
SAFELY TO THEIR LOVED ONES OR
TO THEIR TO THEIR PLACE OF
SAFETY.
SO WELL WITH THAT I'M OPEN TO
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT PROGRAM
WORRY ANY OF OUR OTHER.
.
GRAMS AND WE HAVE.
NO THANK YOU.
THREE COMPLETE.
THEIR LAST WEEK WILL BE GENTLE
MARK FROM THE BUREAU OF HIS
BUREAU CHIEF RETRAINING. PROGRAM
SERVICES
THE PROBLEM THAT DATE RESISTING
TRAINS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MORNING.
PAST.
SORT OF A. PART OF WHAT THIS
MORNING FLORIO OFFICIAL.
MAY TAKE AMINUTE TO GET OUT OF
SALUTE THANK YOU KNOW THE INS
AND JENNA'S FROM POSTS WHICH IS
STAFFERS THAT PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. WILL
PROVIDE THE TRAINING STANDARDS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA OPERATIONAL
SIRS
.
SO GOOD MORNING YES I'M JOHN A
MONTH WITH A PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
I AM A RETIRED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER RISKE TWENTY THREE YEARS
THE SAN JOSE POLICE DEPARTMENT
RETIRED AS A SERGEANT. AND THREE
AND A HALF YEARS AGO I CAME TO
WORK FOR POST AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONSULTANT.
AT THE TIME I GOT HIRED THE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN AND TWENTY
NINE WERE JUST GETTING STARTED.
AND BEING THE NEW GAL WITH NO
NEW RESPONSIBILITIES I'M I WAS
ASSIGNED TO.
KIND OF FOLLOW THE LEGISLATION
WAS SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE AND BECOME WHAT POST RECALL
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT IN TERMS
OF THE TRAINING.
I'M SO I'VE BEEN WITH IT PRETTY
MUCH SINCE THE BEGINNING. AND.
BECAUSE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED OF ME I THOUGHT I
COULD GIVE A LITTLE BACKGROUND
TO SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE IS TO JUST KIND OF PLUNGING
INTO THIS TO THE DATA THE
STATISTICS.
SO THE LEGISLATION WAS.
.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WENT INTO
LAW AND THERE WERE TWO PIECES TO
IT SENATE BILL ELEVEN. AND
SENATE BILL ELEVEN HAD THE BASIC
COURSE REVIEW SORT MANDATED POST
TO LOOK AT THE POLICE ACADEMY
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
INDETERMINATE OR NOT WE WERE.
GIVING ENOUGH INFORMATION AND
TRAINING TO OFFICERS TO BE
COMPETENT TO COMPETENTLY HANDLE
INCIDENTS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES.
.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AS WELL AS
CO OCCURRING DISORDERS.
AND THEN THEY ALSO MANDATED
POSTED A VAL UP AND MAKE
AVAILABLE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS A TRAINING COURSE.
IT WAS A MANDATE FOR POST TO
CREATE THE COURSE BUT IT WAS NOT
MANDATED FOR OFFICERS TO TAKE
THE COURSE.
S. B. TWENTY NINE COMPONENTS I'M
FOCUSED ON THE FIELD TRAINING
OFFICERS THEY WERE TO RECEIVE
EIGHT HOURS. OF TRAINING.
AND THE RISK CRITERIA
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED THAT
WOULD BE CONTAINED IN THAT
TRAINING. OR THEY HAD OF GOING
TO A FORTY HOUR CRISS
INTERVENTION COURSE IF THEY'D
ATTENDED A FORTY HOUR CRISIS
INVENTION QUOTE.
INTERVENTION COURSE IT WAVED THE
EIGHT HOUR REQUIREMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THEY ARE SUPPOSE TO
REVIEW THE COMPETENCIES IN THE
FTO PROGRAM.
AND TO INSTILL FORMER HOURS OF
TRAINING FOR THE F. TEO'S.
AND THEN REVIEW THE COMPETENCIES
IN THE ECONOMY IN FILTERING
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
WERE.
MEETING EVERYTHING THAT WAS
REQUIRED BY THE LAWS.
I AM JUST SO ACCUSE ANYBODY
DIDN'T KNOW THESE BILLS HAD NO
FUNDING ATTACHED TO THEM.
SO POST RESPONSE WE HAVE
LEGISLATION I'M LIKE THIS A AND
WILL BE BACK UP JUST A LITTLE
BIT. NO POST.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE IT BUT
IT'S VOLUNTARY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BELONG TO
POST THEY DON'T HAVE TO YOU. I'M
SO JUST BECAUSE WE TELL PEOPLE
THAT THEY HAVE TO GET TRAINING
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GET TRAINING
LISTED BELONG TO US. UNLESS IT'S
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED.
OUR RESPONSE RESPONSE TO THIS
IT THESE TWO PIECES OF LOS WERE
OF FIRST THING WE DID WAS WE
BROUGHT TOGETHER SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS TO REVIEW THE ACADEMY
CURRICULUM AND WE INCLUDED.
ANTHEM MIL ALUNOS ATTORNEY FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
SUPER. SUPER WONDERFUL WOMAN
COOPERATE EXPERTS.
AND WE LOOKED AT THE CURRICULUM
WHICH WAS SIX HOURS LONG AT THE
TIME. AND.
BEEFED UP TO FIFTEEN HOURS AND
THAT THAT SATISFY THE CIVIC
MATTER EXPERTS IN TERMS OF. WHAT
POLICE RECRUITS WERE GETTING?
NEXT WE REVIEWED AND UPDATED THE
I'M SORRY BROUGHT TOGETHER
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS REVIEWED
UPDATED BASIC COURSE CURRICULUM.
IT FELL ON ME TO THEN CLICK
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO CREATE
THE POST COURSE WHICH WAS THE
SMALLER SHORTER COURSE WE CAME
UP WITH A FOUR HOUR COURSE. IT'S
AVAILABLE ONLINE FOR ANY AGENCY
TO DOWNLOAD AND USE WE CAN
CERTIFY FOR THEM AND USE OF
THEIR AGENCY TO TEACH.
WE EVEN MET THE FOR OUT THE
FOUR HOUR COURSE RECRUIT
REQUIREMENT IN THE FORTY HOUR.
SO FILL TRAINING OFFICERS FROM
THEIR POINT A TO OFFICE HAVE TO
GO TO A FORTY HOUR COURSE TO
TEACH THEM HOW TO BE TRAINING
OFFICERS. WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
THAT COURSE WE WILL FOUR HOURS
OF THE S. B. ELEVEN SP TWENTY
NINE TRAINING CRITERIA INTO IT.
AND A LOT OF IT WE DID BY
FILMING NEW VIDEOS THAT SHOWED
OFFICERS INTERACTING WITH PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES OR MENTAL
HEALTH.
MOST AND FOCUS ON CRISIS TYPE.
SITUATIONS AND TEACHING THE
BILL TRAINING OFFICERS HOW TO
COACH THE RECRUITS TO THOSE
TYPES OF SITUATIONS.
AND THEN FOR WHAT I SAW WAS A
NEED FOR THE FIELD WAS. THE KNOW
HOW THIS EIGHT HOUR STANDALONE
CORE SET OF TOOLS HAVE TO GO TO
AND A LOT OF THE THE TRAINING
OFFICERS ARE CALLING IN DIDN'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CRITERION THE MANDATES WERE. SO.
I HELPED THEM TO CREATE AN
EIGHT HOUR OUTLINE FOR THE FTO
COURSE POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE SO
YOU NEED TO SEE THAT WANTED TO
DO THE COURSE ON THEIR OWN.
COULD DOWNLOAD IT CERTIFIED
THROUGH ME WE MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAD GOOD QUALIFIED
INSTRUCTORS AND TEACH THE COURSE
ON THEIR OWN.
AND LAST FALL WE PUT UP BUT DID
YOU KNOW VIDEO WHICH A LOT OF
THE OFFICERS LIKE IT HELPS TO
ADVERTISE LOOK WE NEED MORE
TRAINING.
SO THE TRUTH CRITERIA THAT WAS
BROUGHT FORTH IN THE BILL'S.
WAS THAT THEIR TRAINING HAD TO
BE CLASSROOM BASED SO THEY
COULDN'T GET IT OFF THE
INTERNET.
INSTRUCTOR LED AND A BIG ONE.
WAS STIGMA REDUCTION AND
CULTURALLY RELEVANT.
NO ONE I WAS ASSIGNED TO MENTAL
HEALTH TRAINING CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING OPPOSED I
TOOK IT UPON MYSELF TO DOWNLOAD
REVIEW EVERY SINGLE COURSE THAT
EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
ALREADY HAD IN PLACE AT THE TIME
THAT BILLS. AND BELIEVE ME THERE
ARE A LOT OF THEM THIS OWN
TRAINING WAS NOT NEW TRAINING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT MANY MANY
AGENCIES HAD INVESTED A LOT OF
TIME AND EFFORT INTO TRAINING
THEIR OFFICERS IN FACT SOMEONE
CPT. A MEDICINAL COUNTY HAS HAD
FORTY OUR COURSES SINCE THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES THAT THEY
BROUGHT OVER FROM MEMPHIS
TENNESSEE.
BUT WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL WAS I DIDN'T
FIND ANY OF THEM THAT ADDRESS
CULTURAL RELEVANCY. AND.
THE BILL'S DUE TO INTRODUCE
THAT ASPECT TO IT. BECAUSE
NATURE INDICATORS
APPROPRIATE RESPONSES TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN CRISIS. ON CONFLICT
RESOLUTION DE ESCALATION IN
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS.
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE TO.
.
ADDRESS MOSTLY DISTRUST
INDIVIDUALS. COMEDIAN STATE
RESOURCES AND PERSPECTIVE OF
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS.
SO I WAS ASKED NGUYEN.
AND ASTRONAUTS THE QUESTION YOU
KNOW WHY DOES THE TRAINING LOOKS
A PIECEMEAL WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS. AND HERE'S THE REASON
THAT IT LOOKS PIECEMEAL IS. USED
TO HOP THESE COURSES F. TEO'S
ARE MANDATED TO DO EIGHT HOURS
OR IF THEY HAD A FORTY YEAR
FORTY HOUR COURSE AND THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO THE EIGHT HOURS.
SO LOOKING AT THE TRAIN CRITERIA
OVERLAP THERE IS FORGIVENESS IF
YOU ALREADY HAD A FORTY HOUR
COURSE.
.
S. B. ELEVEN SP TWENTY NINE HAVE
THE SAME EXACT CRITERIA WITH
VENOM THOUGH THERE'S A LITTLE
LAST FOR S. B. ELEVEN.
AND SO THERE'S THAT KIND OF AN
OVERLAP IF YOU HAD FORTY THEN
YOU DON'T NEED THE EIGHT AND IF
YOU. HAVE THE EIGHT.
THAT YOU HAD BUT IF YOU HAD
ANOTHER COURSE YOU STILL HAVE TO
HAVE THE AIDS THERE'S ALL THIS
OVERLAPPING WITH THE TRAINING
WHICH IS WHY IT DOES LOOK
PIECEMEAL THAT AND.
THE NUMBERS AND HERE'S THE
NUMBERS.
IN A VERY SHORT TIMEFRAME THESE
TO NOT GO BACK TO JUNE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THIS IS JUST
JUNE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO
FABRIC TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. UM
TRAINING THIS BEEN DELIVERED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THAT'S SB
ELEVEN AS BETWEEN NINE AS WELL
AS OTHER MENTAL HEALTH COURSES
LIKE THE LA ESOS THIRTY TWO HOUR
COURSE.
SO IN BASIC COURSE IN THIS TIME
PERIOD. THIRTY PRISONERS PUT ON
SIXTY TWO PRESENTATIONS AND RICH
TWO THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX POLICE RECRUITS.
FOR SENATE BILL ELEVEN WHICH IS
AGAIN THE DOWNLOADER CORSETS NON
MANDATED COURSE. EIGHT PRISONERS
PUT ON NINETY SIX PRESENTATION
RICH TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTY
SEVEN STUDENTS.
GUS IS A LOT ABOUT WHERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS RIGHT NOW IN THE
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW POOR IN THIS
TRAINING IS. BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT RECEIVE ANY FUNDING TO DO
THIS TRAINING THEY ON THEIR OWN.
DOWNLOADED THE COURSE SAID OKAY
LET'S OFFER THIS.
SENATE BILL TWENTY NINE WE HAD
TWENTY TWO PRESENTERS SEVENTY
TWO PRINT PRESENTATIONS ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE STUDENTS.
NOW THAT'S THE EIGHT OUR STAND
ALONE COURSE FOR FTA OWES BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE STUDENTS WERE JUST FTA
OWES LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
HAVE BEEN SENDING ALL OF THEIR
PERSONNEL TO THE CLASS.%
OTHER COURSES SOME THE
PRESENTERS WERE OVERLAPPING SO I
DIDN'T INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF
THEM THERE WERE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE PRESENTATIONS OF
OTHER TYPES OF MENTAL HEALTH
COURSES ARE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY COURSES. AND FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED TWELVE
STUDENTS WERE REACHED.
SO IN A RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME EIGHT MONTHS YOU HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED NINETEEN
PRESENTATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH TEN THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TRAINED IN
THESE PRESENTATIONS.
BUT BUT INFERENCES. FARMHOUSE
CLOSELY THOUSAND PERSONNEL SO I
MEAN TEN THOUSANDS.
IT'S REALLY IN THAT IS THAT IS
THE DROP IN THE BUCKET COMPARED
TO THE NUMBER OF LOT FOR SMALL
SIR STATEWIDE.
SO THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
LA US SO I BELIEVE AS MOST OF
THE AGENCIES THAT HAVE FORTY
HOUR COURSES DON'T JUST OFFER
THEIR COURSES TO THEIR OWN
OFFICERS THEY OPEN THEM UP TO
OTHER AGENCIES. AND THAT MIGHT
BE DROPPED BACK TO BE LOOK AT
LAPD THEY HAVE TEN THOUSAND
OFFICERS BUT THEY'VE BEEN
TEACHING THESE COURSES FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS. SO WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO START AT GROUND
ZERO IN TEACHING OFFICERS ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THERE'S ALREADY
BEEN SUBSTANTIAL GROUND GAINED
IN TRAINING PEOPLE THOUGHT
SUPPORT TO KEEP UPDATED TRAINING
FOR THEM AS WELL. PRODUCTS OF
THE IS A BIGGER ISSUE THAT ONE
ISSUE I HAVE IS FUNDING BECAUSE
THE STATE. MANDATES A LOT OF
COURSES.
THAT HE WILL DO THIS EXPLAINS
THE BUT YET FUNDING IS NOT
PROVIDED SO IT'S BEEN A BIG
ISSUE. YOU TALK ABOUT TRAINING
THEY'LL T. PERSONAL SKILLS I
MEAN. WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT.
AMONG HIS ORGANIZATIONS THEY
HAVE A FINITE NUMBER OF DOLLARS
FOR TRAINING.
AND THEY'RE GONNA PERSONAL
SKILLS IMPORTANT SIDE WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THAT OF COURSE OF
COURSE.
SO FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
IF THEY BELONG TO THE POST
PROGRAM THEY HAVE TO RECEIVE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF CONTINUING
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING EVERY TWO
YEARS. AND FOURTEEN HOURS OF IT
IS MANDATED FOR PERSONAL SKILLS
WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE TO DO
COMMUNICATIONS TRAINING.
EMERGENCY VEHICLE OPERATIONS
FIREARMS TRAINING IN DEFENSIVE
TACTICS.
FIREARMS IN THE IRAQ THERE TO
THE MOST EXPENSIVE COURSES THAT
CAN BE OUT THERE AND THEY CAN
RANGE UP TO SIX TO EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY JUST TEACHING
OFFICER.
FOR THE TUITION ALONE IF YOU
LOOK AT TRAVEL COST YOU COULD BE
AVERAGE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A DAY FOR A LONG
FORSMAN OFFICER. IN THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE COST OF WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET HIM OFF THE STREET
BUT WHAT IS THE AGENCY PAYNG IN
OVERTIME TO COVER THEM AS WELL.
SO TRAINING IF YOU LOOK AT AN
EIGHT HOUR LET'S LOOK AT EIGHT
HOUR COURSELET'S NOT THINK TALK
ABOUT BACK PAY. IT'S A
REASONABLE OFTEN OFFICER ATTENDS
AN EIGHT HOUR. IN CLASSROOM
COURSES DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY YOU
KNOW FANCY EQUIPMENT WOULD BE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR TROUBLE COSTS INTO
HER FIFTY DOLLARS TUITION.
IF YOU MULTIPLY THAT TIMES
EIGHTY THOUSAND OFFICERS THAT'S
I THINK ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO TRAIN EVERY
OFFICER IN THE STATE.
THIS EXPENSIVE. SO I KNOW POSTED
THOUGHT OBVIOUSLY IF THAT BACK
OVER YEARS GOING BACK IN TIME.
THEIR BILL LOT MORE MANDATES.
PUT ALL POST.
FOR TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
BUT THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
LACK OF FUNDING.
GIVEN THE POST BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
THAT IS CORRECT WE GET A LOT OF
UNFUNDED MANDATES.
SO THAT THAT'S A BIG ISSUE KEEP
ISSUING RULES AND WE WANT TO DO
THIS THIS THIS AND THIS AND
THIS.
AND YET IS NOT BEING FUNDED.
SO YOU NOT FORCES CAN WE JUST
LOOK LIKE ON THE THE IMPORTANT
SKILLS.
FIRE TRAINING DRIVING PERSONAL
SKILLS SO THEY JUST UP IN SOME
DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO IT. AND GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND AND YOU KNOW SOME DEL
BECAUSE YOU'RE THOUGH YOU GIVE
THAT BUDGET BY YOU THE BOARD
SUPERVISORS OR. YOU KNOW CITY
COUNCIL SO IT IS A TOUGH
SITUATION SO.
IT'S CRACKED YEAH THANK YOU.
THINKING NO EASY ANSWERS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS NO.
THOMAS I WOULD OPEN UP A PUBLIC
COMMENT SO THOSE FOLKS WISHING
TO SPEAK.
PLEASE OPPOSE MICROPHONE LET ME
HEAR FROM YOUR THOUGHTS AND
COMMENTS.
IT.
MORNING.
CHAIRMAN.
VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE AFTER.
I AM.
NOT ENOUGH FOR THE FOR THE ROOM.
OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME NO YOU HAVE
WHAT'S BETTER DEBORAH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN COOPER FOR HOLDING THE
HEARING ALSO APPRECIATE THE
COURTESIES OF. YOUR STAFF.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON THE
PHONE MR ZIGLAR AND I AND SO I
AM I AM AWARE OF.
SERVICE ARE YOU BOTH HAVE
PROVIDED IN THE FACT THAT YOU DO
HAVE TRAINING AND THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT THAT YOU KNOW QUITE
A BIT ABOUT IN TERMS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTING. WITH
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR LAST
WITNESS.
THIS MONK WHO GAVE A SHOUT OUT
TO ONE OF OUR ATTORNEYS.
POP UP KAMALA LIEU OF WE TRY TO.
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH.
OTHERS WHO ARE SHARING OUR GOALS
OF TRYING TO.
PROMOTE THE RIGHTS AND
INDEPENDENCE AND DIGNITY OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
THE PRIMARY REASON I WANTED TO
COME UP HERE AND AND SPEAK
TODAY.
I IS THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE NOT IN
FAVOR OF A BILL THAT GOT
MENTIONED.
AB FOR THIRTY SEVEN FROM LAST
YEAR AND I KNOW THAT SO MANY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE SPOKE ABOUT SO
MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND SO I
I. DON'T WANT TO SUGGEST THAT
WE'RE CRITICAL OF THIS PROGRAM A
CRITICAL OF THAT PROGRAM. THEIR
WIT THERE WAS.
THIS THE IDEA OF THE STATEWIDE
REGISTRY.
AND WE.
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
SOMEONE WITH A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY WHO IS ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR HIMSELF OR HERSELF
DIDN'T WANT TO BE ON THAT
REGISTRY.
OR IF A CONSERVATIVE OR WHO
DIDN'T NECESSARILY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS HAPPENS
SOMETIMES DIDN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
CONSERVATIVE AT HEART.
WE WHAT WE WE HAD A PROBLEM
WITH THAT BUT WE WERE APPARENTLY
VERY CLOSE I WASN'T WORKING ON
pWORKING THINGS OUT WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THAT BILL.
FINALLY I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION ALSO THAT.
LISTENING TO ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT APPROACHES REMINDED ME
OF SOME OF THE EARLY HEARINGS
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO.
NOW MAYOR STEINBERG WAS
CHAIRING THE STATE'S BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON AUTISM. AND I
REMEMBER HEARING.
SOME DISCUSSION PARTICULARLY BY
ONE MEMBER OF THE COMMISSION
ABOUT THE.
VERY DEEP CONCERN SHE HAD HER
SON WAS ATTENDING COLLEGE AND
AND I DON'T KNOW IF HER SON WAS
EVER GOING TO HAVE A AYE
DIFFICULTIES IN THE COMMUNITY.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM.
MAY SAY THE WRONG THING TO A
POLICE OFFICER YOU YOU YOU
HEARD.
I THINK MORE THAN ONE PERSON
EXPLAINED THAT IF IT IF THERE
HASN'T BEEN TRAINING IF POLICE
OFFICER DOESN'T REALLY KNOW.
WHAT A CERTAIN BEHAVIOR MIGHT
WE ARE NOT LOOKING YOU IN THE
EYE AND SO IS IT'S VERY
HEARTENING?
I SEE TEN YEARS LATER THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF ACTIVITY.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON WHATEVER MAY FOLLOW
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU GOING KNOWLEDGE A
SALOON A CERVANTES FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. THANK YOU KNOW
EVEN IN COMMITTEE THANKS FOR
MAKING IT DOWN HERE.
MY NAME'S JEFF TARGET HERE AND I
DO EXPECT TO SEE YOU MISTER
COOPER LATER ON THIS MONTH
PERSONALLY. WILL WORK ON THEIR
BOTTOM I APPRECIATE THIS AND I'M
HOPING THAT THIS WILL BE
AVAILABLE AND MORE WIDESPREAD TO
GET THIS INFORMATION OUT. I KNOW
ONCE YOU IN SACRAMENTO IS IS IT
STILL WORKING ON OUR DEAR MAYOR.
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND THE FACT
THAT NOT ALL OF HIS OFFICERS ARE
EVEN YET TRAINED IN
UNDERSTANDING MENTAL HEALTH. IT
IS SOMETHING THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY REALLY
NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND.
THESE PROBLEMS. AND YEAH I'M
COMING ON THAT'S A GREAT COMMENT
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S A.
THE STATE HAS A SURPLUS BUDGET
THIS YEAR THEY HAVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS.
SO IF YOU IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
REALLY THEY COULD.
AND THERE TRANSMIT MONEY
EVERYWHERE ON EVERYTHING BUT.
SINCE THIS IS BEEN IT'S BEEN THE
NEWS ALL OVER THE PLACE WE KNOW
ABOUT IT WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH
FOLKS.
THEY'RE MENTALLY ILL WE'VE SEEN
SOME INTERACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
SO GREAT.
SO WHY NOT A BETTER TIME TO YOU
SOME OF THE EXCESS FUNDS.
FOR TRAINING.
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THAT'S
THAT'S PART WHERE YOU GOT
COMMAND. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
SAYING IT NOW WITH COMMUNICANTS
IN TOGETHER AS A WHOLE.
TO FIGHT THAT YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
SOME THIS MORNING GIVE THESE
FOLKS TRAINED.
SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
INCIDENTS.
AND LASTLY O. ALSO MAKE A
COMMENT THIS IS PLEASE CHECK
WITH THE AUTHOR OF. OF S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY THREE THIS IS
DEALING WITH THE YEAR. SHE WAS
THE EMERGENCY CONTACT BECAUSE A
OF FOR THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
THAT IS WHAT WHO'S DETERMINED AS
WELL AS OTHERS THAT COME SIMPLY.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT REACH
OUT AND HOW TO MAKE THAT
EXPRESSION ONLY AND THAT'S A
BILL THAT WAS THIS MORNING
DISCUSSED EIGHT THIRTY THREE
DEALING WITH THE YEAR. HOME WITH
THE EMERGENCY.
ALERT SYSTEM.
HOME SO ANYWAY.
GUYS APPRECIATE LISTENING TO
YOU THIS ROOM MADE A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO SHOW IN HERE SO I
JUST CAME IN LIKE THIS IN HERE.
AND I WILL GO ON TO A.
OTHER HEARINGS TODAY AND TO
HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSION SEWING
APPLICANT IN YES GROW VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS DOG FIGHT
CALIFORNIA FOR ALLIANCE A
RETIRED AMERICANS.
I'M AND ALL AND OTHER ISSUES
THAT TO ALL OF WHICH ARE THINGS
THAT TO.
THE DISABILITY.
IS SOMETHING IS ASKEW
UNDERSTANDING A RECOGNIZING IN
DETERMINING THE DIFFERENCE OF
WHAT THAT BEHAVIOR IS LIKE THANK
YOU AGAIN.
NO CERVANTES THAT WITH THE
COMMENTS BUT I JUST. KNOW I I
JUST CERTAINLY APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR ACTUALLY BRINGING
THIS TO THE FOREFRONT HOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HEAR
FROM ALL PERSPECTIVES I
ESPECIALLY FROM OUR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY. AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT.
IMPACTS MANY RESIDENTS AND
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROL MEDINA
AND I'M FROM SANDRA DINO COUNTY.
AND I A WOULD.
LIKE TO SHARE THAT MY SON.
HE'S A CLIENT OF INLAND
REGIONAL CENTER AND HE DOES HAVE
THE IF I NEED HELP LABELS.
AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU GUYS THAT. YOU KNOW HE'S
ABOUT TO BE EIGHTEEN.
AND.
.
I'M GONNA.
CONSERVATIVE RIGHTS ASIDE I'M
GONNA LET MY SON HAVE A ACCESS
TO PERSONAL CHOICES HAVING IS
DISABILITIES.
AND SO HE'S GOING TO NEED TO
HAVE A LOT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
SUPPORTS.
AND AS AN INDIVIDUAL ON THE
SPECTRUM IN WITH THAT SOME.
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES TO
WHERE YOU KNOW YOU MAY NOT KNOW
HIS WHEREABOUTS HE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO READ. HE CAN VERBALLY
COMMUNICATE HOWEVER ON HIS.
IF I NEED HELP.
IT SAYS.
THAT.
.
HE IT IT LABELS HIS
DISABILITIES.
AND IT SAYS CITY HE NEEDS A LOT
OF INFORMATION THAT HE ASK
QUESTIONS AND THAT HE NEEDS
INFORMATION AS WELL.
AND THAT HE'S TACTILE DEFENSIVE
AND THAT HE'S GOTTEN HIS MEDICAL
ISSUES FOR. GEE I.
.
THEN OTHER HEALTH IMPAIRMENTS AS
WELL AND SO I'M.
BEEN IT IS EIGHTEEN I DON'T GET
TO BE A HOWEVER MOM ANYMORE.
SO THAT THAT FALLS ON TO THE
STATE IN THE DEPARTMENT TO.
MAINTAIN WORKABLE RELATIONSHIP.
A.
ON A SIDE NOTE I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THAT MY SON.
HAS HAD A PREVIOUS HEAD INJURY
FROM.
PROP GROUP PRONE RESTRAINT.
AND THAT WAS BECAUSE HE AYE.
HE HAS SLOW PROCESSING IT
DOESN'T.
RESPOND IMMEDIATELY TO
COMMUNICATION ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
OUR INITIAL COMMUNICATION AND SO
HE WOULD BE SLOW TO RESPOND BUT
THE SAME TIME. WHEN HE'S TRYING
TO COMMUNICATE BECAUSE HE'S
HIGHLY VERBAL. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME HE DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION WHERE HE
WOULD KNOW IT DATED DATED IS.
LOOK HIS OWN ADDRESS
THINGS TO THAT.
CRITICAL INFORMATION LIFE
INFORMATION HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION SO THEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE A GIVE AND TAKE
OF COMMUNICATION THAT WOULD HAVE
TO OCCUR.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE HEAD INJURY I
HAVE FEARS.
BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW. WHAT IF NOW THAT IS AN
ADULT MEAN OUR WE GONNA HAVE THE
SAME ISSUE INTO ADULTHOOD?
VERSES HIS CHILDHOOD.
AND.
.
I AS A MOM.
LEGITIMATELY HAVE FEARS.
BECAUSE.
I NEED TO KNOW THAT HE'S GOING
TO BE SAFE. IN THIS WORLD
NAVIGATING AS AN ADULT WITH YOU
KNOW HIS PEERS OR ANYBODY ELSE
OUTSIDE OF MY I'M OBSERVATION.
OUTSIDE OF MY PARENTS TOLD
ADVOCACY.
THEY HE'S GONNA NEED TO HAVE
SOME TYPE OF SUPPORT AS WELL IN
PLACE.
OTHER WAYS YOU KNOW IT A TYPICAL
PERSON SAY LIKE EVEN MYSELF I'M
INTERACTING WOULD GO IS HEAVING
A SMART ALECK.
YOU KNOW WHY WHY IS HE BEHAVING
THIS WAY YOU KNOW IT'S IS IT
WILL WHAT IS HE DIGGING THAT. TO
TO. TO GET BACK AT ME OR
SOMEBODY ELSE AND RELEASE JUST
EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION THE
GIVING TAKE THE AWKWARDNESS.
A AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
UNDERSTOOD.
SO.
WHENEVER THERE'S DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS THERE'S PROCESSING DELAYS
FARES SETBACKS AND SO WE NEED TO
HAVE THESE COVERED SO THAT WAY.
UP FOR AN INDIVIDUAL SAFETY IT'S
MATT.
SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT BY BLOW TO
A GROUP CALLED DOC BUT WHICH IS
DISABILITIES GROUP HERE KNOW
THAT SACRAMENTO.
A LEGACY YET MANDATORY.
CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING.
HELLO THE SEA EVERY OFFICER
TRAINED AL HUNT THEY DE ESCALATE
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL DISABILITIES
OR PFT V..
I LIKED ALSO SEE HOW IT'S
WORKING A YEARLY REVIEW HOW MUCH
WORKING IN THE IT ALL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA I WAS YOU KNOW
SITUATIONS WHERE THE POLICE
OFFICERS.
KILL THE JOSEPH MAN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUPLE YEARS AGO I
DON'T SEE THAT NO MORE.
BECAUSE IF TO HEAR THE HOMELESS
GUY WHO WOULD BET MENTAL
DISABILITY IN THE PLEASE I
DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO.
DO FDF TRAINING ON HIM.
BECAUSE THE PARTY WASN'T TRAINED
WELL ENOUGH.
I LIKE TO SEE ALL POLICE
OFFICERS TRAINED.
ON HOW DO PDF GET LATE.
SITUATIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE WILL BORROW.
I'M FROM LOS BANOS CALIFORNIA.
HER WORLD TOWN AND.
I CAME HERE WITH MY UNION UAW.
ON LAW AND I'M REALLY PROUD TO
BE A PART OF MY UNION.
I AM A AND HOME HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. TO THE IHS US PROGRAM
WHICH IS AND HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
AND.
I HAVE A CHILD WHO IS NINE
YEARS OLD.
WHO IS MODERATE SEVERE AUTISM
WITH VOCABULARY EXTREME
VOCABULARY?
SO HERE WE GO INTO SPECTRUM.
MY CHILD HAS COMMUNICATION
SKILLS AND I BUT HE DOES NOT
PRAGMATIC SO BASICALLY THERE IS
NO MEANINGFUL.
REAL COMMUNICATION HOW GO ON AND
ON ABOUT.
LEGOS MINECRAFT WOULD YOU LIKE
SEE CAN USE BIG WORDS HE CAN
READ HE'S GOT AN IQ OF A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY BUT HE HAS THE
FUNCTIONAL.
AND
SKILLS OF PROBABLY AT OF FIVE
YEAR OLD CHILD IN REGARDS TO
SAFETY.
AND SELF AWARENESS.
.
EXTREMELY RATIONAL ON VIOLENT AT
TIMES.
AND IMPULSIVE.
BECAUSE HE I AM.
PERCEIVES OUTSIDE STIMULI IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAN YOU AN IDEA
IS NOT NARROW TYPICAL THAT WAY.
SOMETIMES WHEN I GO TO GENTLY
TOUCH HER SHOULDER. HIS FIRST
REACTION IS TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
FOR MY CHILD AND NINE YEARS OLD
HE'S HALFWAY TO A TEAM.
THIS.
IT'S VERY SCARY TO ME BECAUSE.
I FEAR FOR THE SAFETY OF THE AN
HOUR THOSE AROUND HIM AND FOR
HIS OWN SAFETY BECAUSE.
AND NOW EVEN NOW IN A PUBLIC
SCHOOL ONE AND YOU KNOW I STC
CLASSROOM WHICH IS A SPECIAL DAY
CLASS HE'S ALSO ON.
PUBLIC CAMPUS WHICH MEANS THAT
OTHER CHILDREN.
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO KNOW THAT
HE'S DISABLED OR WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH HIM SO A SIX GREATER THAT
HE'S OUT ON THE YARD WAS DURING
THE DAY YOU.
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THAT HE'S
TRYING TO RUN AWAY.
TWO AVOID CONFLICTS.
ANNIE IS PROBABLY YOU KNOW HE'S
ANA MANIFESTED TERMINATION NOW
WHICH MEANS THAT HE IS GONE
VIOLENT ENOUGH AT SCHOOL TO BE
SUSPENDED SOMETIMES.
HE STILL SUBJECT TO THE SAME
AMOUNT OF DISCIPLINE AS AN
ARTICLE CHILD.
THERE IS NO OTHER PROGRAM FOR
HIM SO THE NEXT STEP FOR MY
CHILD IF THIS CONTINUES IS TO
HAVE.
INTERVENTION WITH A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
OR A SOCIAL WORKER OR ANOTHER.
YOU NOW AUTHORITY FIGURE THAT
WILL HAVE TO COME AND ASSESS THE
SCHOOL.
AND THESE PROGRAMS ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
DID HE BECOME ST. BECAUSE I A
PRETTY SURE WE DON'T HOW ABOUT
PROGRAM MINERAL LOS BANOS
DEFINITELY.
SURE.
AND A LOT OF TIMES.
.
I FEAR THAT IF I'M IN A CAR
ACCIDENT I'M RENDERED
UNCONSCIOUS THAT MY CHILD REALLY
LOW FROM THE VEHICLE.
AND IF THERE'S NO WAY FOR
OFFICERS TO KNOW BY RUNNING MY
PLAY OR EVEN MY ID CARD.
MY CHILD COULD BE RUNNING DOWN
HIGHWAY AND GET HIT TOLD BY
VEHICLE BECAUSE THAT INFORMATION
IS UNAVAILABLE.
.
A POLICE OFFICER WHO MY APPROACH
MY CHILD AS AN ADULT MAY FEEL.
THAT.
THERE THREATENS
AND THEREFORE HAVE TO RESPOND IN
NOW IN A WAY THAT CAN BE AVOIDED
BECAUSE THAT INFORMATION. COULD
HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE TO POLICE
OFFICER.
AND I HAVE A HUSBAND WHO HAS A
BRAIN INJURY IN PTSD AS WELL AND
LET ME TELL YOU.
THERE IS A LOT OF SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN PTSD.
AND SO OFTEN SOME BECAUSE IT'S A
FIRE FIGHT RESPONSE WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE.
THE LANGUAGE OR THE ABILITY TO
REGULATE YOURSELF EMOTIONALLY.
.
SO I KNOW FROM MY HUSBAND IF HE
GETS ARRESTED THERE OR. AGENCIES
ARE WAYS TO IDENTIFY.
AND TO REACH OUT TO THE VA SO
THAT MY HUSBAND DOESN'T END UP
YOU KNOW IN A SITUATION WHERE
HE'S.
IT DEALT WITH UNFAIRLY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS ACTUALLY VERY RELATED TO
MILITARY. AND UNDERSTAND PTSD SO
I THINK WE JUST BRING US
AWARENESS OUR ROUNDS TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE.
MENTAL AND INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES WE CAN ALSO CREATE
THE SAME SYSTEM. THAT WILL KEEP
NOT ONLY OUR OFFICER SAFE BUT
OUR KIDS SAVE.
MAN ARE ADULTS THAT HAVE MENTAL
ILLNESS AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY SAFE AND IT'S
NECESSARY FOR ALL OF THE
OFFICERS.
AND ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED WITH SO THAT WE CAN
PREVENT.
.
ENORMOUS TREATMENT. OR.
ES SITUATION THAT ESCALATES TO
A POINT THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED. I THINK IT'D BE
REALLY GREAT TO SEE FUNDING ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL FOR FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE DISCUSSED
HERE TODAY. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LISA
COLEMAN I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CHALCO AYE THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
HOW I AM BUDS MEN'S ARE AT THE
ADVOCATES FOR RESIDENTS THAT
LIVE IN LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES AND CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THOSE BEDS? BUT WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION SENIORS OLDER ADULTS
THAT HAVE ACTIVITIES OF DAILY
LIVING THAT REQUIRE CARE GIVING.
SO.
I'M HERE TO SAY THAT THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY IS BROADER
THAN JOSH. ODD THE DD COMMUNITY
IT'S BROADER THAN OUR OLDER
ADULTS.
IT'S IT'S BROADER THAN A
FINANCIAL ASK THAT LAW. LAW
ENFORCEMENT GET THIS TRAINING WE
AS CITIZENS NEED TO GET THIS
TRAINING THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION OF HOW DO WE DEAL
WITH ONE ANOTHER IS BROADER THAN
JUST LAW ENFORCEMENT. ARM IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN MY HUSBAND AND
I SPENT NEW YEAR'S EVE SEARCHING
FOR AN OLDER GENTLEMAN ELK GROVE
WHO HAD WANDERED OFF.
AND BOB IT WAS A SILVER ALERT
THAT CAME THROUGH OUR CELL
PHONES THAT THAT GOT US IN.
GODDESS WALKING OUT ON NEW
YEAR'S EVE AND UNFORTUNATELY WE
GAVE UP WE DIDN'T FIND AND WE
GAVE UP ON. THE GOOD NEWS WISE
WE LEARNED LATER THAT HE WAS
FOUND ON THE FRUSTRATING NEWS
WAS WE WERE OUT AN HOUR AFTER HE
HAD BEEN FOUND SO MAYBE
SUBSISTENCE TO CALL AN ALL
CLEAR.
WIN THE SILVER ALERT HAS BEEN
FOUND I TAKE HOME THAT SAYS WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL AND WE GOT HIM
HOME WOULD BE HELPFUL.
AND JUST TO BRING ATTENTION.
THE ALERT SYSTEMS WORK.
WHEN YOU HAVE A CARE GIVER
THAT'S.
THAT SIGNING A PERSON NOT.
BUT WE KNOW THAT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF ALL OF
THE PERSONS WITH A DIAGNOSIS OF
ALZHEIMER'S CURRENTLY LIVE
ALONE.
SO THERE WOULDN'T BE A CARE
GIVER TO NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT THIS PERSON IS LAUGHED.
AND WORSE THAN JUST TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THOSE POPULATION.
HE LIVES ALONE WE KNOW THAT
FORTY PERCENT OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THE DISEASE ACTUALLY GET A
DIAGNOSIS.
SO THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF OUR.
CALIFORNIANS OLDER ADULTS THAT
HAVE THESE IMPAIRMENTS
THAT ARE NEVER GONNA MAKE IT
ONTO A REGISTRY.
AND.
.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER BUT I AM
THANKFUL THAT YOU ARE HAVING THE
DISCUSSION.
AS I THINK THEY'RE PEOPLE THAT
ARE MUCH SMARTER THAN I AM THAT
CAN COME AND HELP US MAKE THIS
BETTER WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SHANNON PRIMARILY
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY OF
OCEANSIDE I HAVE A SIXTEEN AND A
HALF YEAR OLD. NONVERBAL AND.
NETSCAPE ARTISTS HE CLIMATE SIX
FOOT FENCE FROM THE TIME HE WAS
FOR.
I ALSO RUN TWO PAGES ON
FACEBOOK FOR MISSING CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM.
TO THAT AS SOON AS WE HEAR A
STORY OF A CHILD NOTHING THAT IT
GETS OUT TO AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE. AND I'M US SPECIAL
NEEDS PARALEGAL SO I'M HERE
REPRESENTING NOT JUST MYSELF BUT
ALL OF MY CLIENTS AND MY MOM'S
NIGHT OUT GROUP. AND I AM A U.
D. W..
WORKER ALSO EVEN THOUGH I'M NOT
HERE WITH THEM I'M ON MY OWN
BOMB BUT PLEASE CONSIDER TRYING
TO GET US A STATEWIDE.
THING WE TRAVEL A LOT TO
ANAHEIM AND MODESTO FROM SAN
DIEGO AND EVEN AUSTIN IS
REGISTERED WITH TAKE ME HOME
THAT DOESN'T DO ME ANY GOOD IF
I'M HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND HE
GETS LOST.
AND HE IS A HUGE FLIGHT ROTH
WHEN IT COMES TO WATER. AND.
TRAFFIC FORD UP FORTY NINE
PERCENT OF OUR KIDS WITH AUTISM
WANDER AWAY AND THE NUMBER ONE
REYES THEY DIE. IS BY EITHER
DROWNING ARE GETTING HIT BY A
CAR AND THAT'S FROM THE NATIONAL
AUTISM ASSOCIATION'S WEBSITE IF
YOU.
CARE TO LOOK IT UP MONTH WE NEED
THIS STATEWIDE WE. WE DON'T WANT
WE NEED THANK YOU GUYS FOR
HAVING THE HEARING. BUT YOU.
HONEY I'M CHRISTIE'S PUBLIC
MERCHANT FROM EDUCATE APPLIQUE.
AND AND. JUST WANTED TO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THIS HEARING AND
LET YOU KNOW THAT.
I THINK THAT WE WOULD REALLY
SUPPORT A STATEWIDE MAGISTRATE
WE HEARD A LOT OF WONDERFUL
PROGRAMS ARE HAPPENING ALL
AROUND THE STATE. AND BUT WE DO
NEED SOMETHING THAT ENCOMPASSES
THE ENTIRE STATE. I'M.
I ALSO THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE.
SOME KIND OF MANDATORY.
POLICE TRAINING.
AND. THERE WAS THE RECENT BUDGET
BILL THAT PASSED THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THAT BROUGHT FORWARD SOME
FUNDING THROUGH CABINET OF
AUNTIES LA.
AND AS ARE THAT'S MOST TRAIN
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS AND ALSO
PROVIDE VOLUNTARY ALERT. I'M
ID'S FOR THOSE WHO WISH FOR
THAT.
BUT THERE THE REGISTRY
DEFINITELY WOULD WANT IT TO BE
I'M VOLUNTARY ALSO I SHIP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU.
DANIEL SEVERE NO ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY ONE
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT REGIONAL
CENTERS. COORDINATE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR OF SOMEONE OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES INCLUDING ALL TO
CALIFORNIAN VALLEY MOUNT
REGIONAL CENTERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
NEWMAN REGIONAL CENTER AS WELL.
THE REGIONAL CENTER IS
ESSENTIALLY.
THE HUB THAT CONNECTS
INDIVIDUALS TO SERVICES.
NO THROUGHOUT THE REGION OF THE
ASSOCIATION AS A WHOLE HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF SUPPORTING THESE
TYPES OF OPPORTUNITIES TO A C.
BETTER OUTCOMES WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SPECIFICALLY BUT
FIRST RESPONDERS GENERALLY ARE
INTERACTING WITH PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES A
BEFORE THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
WORDS PART OF THAT.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS.
REALLY WE ARE ALL HERE ON THE
SAME PAGE OF SEEING BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FOR FAMILIES.
ANY OPPORTUNITY TO HELP MOVE
THIS DISCUSSION FOR GUERRILLA
ALWAYS HAPPY TO BE A PART OF
THANK YOU.
AT.
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE PRESENT
ALSO RECOGNIZE THOSE MEMBERS WHO
ON THIS COMMITTEE BUT COULD NOT
MAKE IT DO OTHER COMMITMENTS.
I WOULD ESPECIALLY THANK THE
PANEL MEMBERS AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS WHO TOOK TIME OUT THEIR
BUSY SCHEDULES TO BE PRESIDENT
AND SHOULD THE PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCES WITH
US.
HAS ALL THOSE WHO PARTICIPATE
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE GO FORWARD YOU MY COMMITMENT
TO KEEP THIS ISSUE IN FRONT.
IN FRONT AND CENTER AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS HELPING
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN.
THE PERSONNEL EMILY DISABLED
PERSONS.
IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO MAKE IT
CLEAR. THAT THE FIRST RESPONDERS
WHEN HALEY'S CULTURE SERVICE IN
WHICH A PERSON WITH A MENTAL
DISABILITIES INVOLVED THEY'LL
ALWAYS RECOGNIZE IT. I DIDN'T.
THE PROGRAM'S APPROACH IS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD AND SEEN TODAY ARE
DESIGNED TO GIVE FIRST
RESPONDERS ITS INFORMATION SO
THEY MAY TAILOR THE RESPONSE. IN
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY WHEN
SERVING THE MENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY. THESE PROGRAMS ARE A
TESTAMENT TO THE LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT OF THE MIDDLE HEALTH
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT LEADERS.
HAVE IN HELPING ONE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IS
MICHAEL THIS THESE PROGRAMS ARE
EXPANDED STATEWIDE.
YOU GUYS ARE VERY POWERFUL GROUP
AND IMPORT THINGS COMING
TOGETHER BOTH SIDES AND YOUR
VOICES CAN AND WILL BE HEARD.
AND IT IT TO ME IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF THINGS
THE NEWS IN BY BEING HERE IS THE
FIRST STEP ONE OF MANY STEPS TO
TAKE.
AND REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE.
BETTER THEIR ACTIONS
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR ANYBODY AT
ALL.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO MAKE OUR
VOICES HEARD LIKE I SAID RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY HERE.
NOT ALWAYS BUT YOU KNOW ONE TIME
MONIES
SO THAT THAT IS AN IDEA. BUT
DEFINITELY GET ALL YOUR
LEGISLATORS YOUR SENATORS AND
YOUR LOCAL FOLKS AND LET HIM
KNOW WE WANT.
IT FUNDED PROPERLY.
SO THANK YOU ALL APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE I'VE GOT ANOTHER
GOD BLESS